all right and we are
live the last word with lord cognito
anybody's
fresh on that friday evening campfire
little special guest action but uh
what's going on here how are you doing
man
i'm doing pretty good you know i got a
workout in this morning got ready
um honestly we have an awesome guest in
here so i don't want to like
wait too long so let's bring him into
the campfire the way you guys know how
we do it
here we go good evening we are back
around the campfire and the friendly
competition of guardian games awaits all
classes next week
with laurels to pick up and medals to
turn in eva levante will be back in the
tower once again
to serve as destiny's grandmother after
that season 14 will be here and while
the name is still redacted
we know some changes are coming and our
guest will always give us
well-constructed opinions
about the future of this game tonight we
are joined by a gentleman who is
seasoned in both life and gaming
sure he started out with some classics
shout out to super mario brothers 3 a
favorite
but he is not just a gamer he's so much
more this man is likely the smartest man
in the room for more often than not
and his work in biomedical engineering
has driven him forward
for the past decade math and science
have built how this man's mind works
which explains why he is so cool calm
and collected
in the heat of battle openness to
discuss any topic
in a constructive manner is what has
helped him build such a positive
community
and while civil discourse is where this
man shines his pvp skills are legendary
if you put a hand cannon in this man's
hand he will likely take you down
and juke you out of your shoes while he
does it
so without further ado let's welcome a
man who has usually
found with a headband on and a notepad
in his hand
he has built one of the best communities
on his road to twitch partner
is welcoming to all walks of life and
proves it by truly caring
about even your pronoun and agrees that
grape nuts are also the gravel of cereal
or for our guest it's 0 or 100
as mediocrity is not an option his goal
in life is mastery for any topic or
skill
and proves it is do or do not there is
no try
let's welcome the own the one the only
ill physics mr tony how are you doing
tonight sir
put your hands together put your hands
together that was an immaculate
introduction there's a little bit of
embellishing here and there
hey hey that's what we gotta do we gotta
do it i'm feeling it i feel it
you know so thank you so much physics
aka tony
if you did not previously know me and uh
it's a pleasure to be here
thank you for having me oh man thank you
very much
um yeah just honestly thank you like i
know i got to see you on a podcast that
it's like i wasn't on but it was on
previously i know you're on um
the one with mario i'm trying to
remember the name of so just anytime
yeah the filler uh while he was doing
that caught you on there and just
enjoy listening to your like takes in
between on twitter it's net it's always
constructive criticism so
happy to have you on here cognito is
even happier than i am to have a pvp
guru on here so
we got some stuff to talk about but
let's get to know you first man a little
bit i know
super mario mother brothers super mario
brothers 3 is literally like
the game that i played you know you get
to world 8 you're like 10 years old and
playing as a kid and you're like i've
spent way too many times on much on this
game but like
just some of the classics you've been
through like what did you start with for
gaming besides those like specific nes
classics
um yeah i guess you know
the origins of gaming for me really
really took it like way back right like
so
a little bit older my my dad worked for
ibm
when i was growing up so we always had
you know pcs
in the house and so even before
i you know got hand me down the nintendo
to play some mario's three et cetera et
cetera
um you know i was playing tetris you
know i was playing uh
different like i can't even remember
some of the names of
uh some of these games but uh you know
your solitaires your
card games your hearts et cetera et
cetera
and so uh you know if there was truly
like an origin of gaming for me it was
it would be between those things and
maybe like some online chess and things
you know my family wasn't huge
into i mean my head was always in a book
my parents definitely kept me rigorous
academic you know uh rigorous academic
calendar
so uh so you know there wasn't like too
much gaming
you know growing up before super mario
bros even before i guess like
right like struck out on my own when i
was uh
15 years old i ended up going to a
boarding school a special boarding
school like here north carolina called
the
colorado school of science and math
excellent excellent school
um and that's probably where i branched
out a little more because i didn't have
you know the
strict destruction over yeah yeah the
strict framework
of my parents you know uh making sure
that i was i was definitely always in a
book for the most part
uh you know my friends definitely played
some uh some
some tekken or you know whatever
whatever you know
doom doom was also like really big back
then of course
yeah that's probably most people's first
shooter i would imagine yeah
yeah wolfenstein 3d yep
i love that game because not only was it
a shooter you know obviously but also it
was a lot of puzzles
you know there's a lot of puzzles
there's a lot of like secrets and things
you had to kind of like find
easter eggs et cetera et cetera what was
your 3d man like they need to bring that
back
hard i mean obviously they're top tier
caliber games that follow kind of a
similar
uh similar uh trope but nonetheless uh
open scene 3d was kind of huge age of
empires
we get into that strategy
yeah yeah because i had i have siblings
as well i have an older sister i have
two younger brothers so
you know between uh them and also my dad
who's also kind of an egghead
uh we used to always like get down with
these things in our spare time like here
there yeah
any turn-based strategy or was you more
of an rts guy
at that time like for example like the
uh i guess the ex-cops would be
considered turn-based
or did that not appear too i mean there
was like years of magic even that far
back so
i'm dating myself too no those that that
was pretty much like the ones that i
listed pretty much the ones that i got
into
you know like i started getting into um
call of duty a lot
like later on so so i didn't play much
games in between
um when i finished up high school and
when i finished up
honestly grad school you know i went
straight from
um of course like high school straight
to college four years there
and then i took two years from my
master's and i did that right after high
school as well
and in in that period of time um
i wasn't really gaming that much at all
um it wasn't
until after grad school and maybe like a
couple years later where i started
getting
back into gaming a little bit uh and i
started playing call of duty
like a lot okay okay so i started that
with
um world at war
mp40 baby
i think it was popping i think it was
popping the heads up
yes
uh zombies i filled them up with zombies
there as well
and then i just kept on playing like
every one afterwards
you know the warfare three uh
[Music]
[Music]
a lot of people have either come through
halo
cod both usually is like a general way
to go through but like cod
i don't know of many people who played
first-person shooters that haven't
played like modern warfare 2 and stuff
like that for example where
that's like it's one of the pillars that
that was the next one after like halo
and halo 3 that like
changed things big time so it's it's a
pillar for sure yeah yeah i would yeah
also i mean call of duty of course was
on all platforms
yes excuse me as opposed to halo which
was only on xbox and that was
that was the reason why i didn't get too
deeply into halo even
when it was hot was because it was on
xbox right so
i think my cousins maybe you know every
once in a while i would
game with them you know over at their
house they only had playstations
oh like the only all the games i ever
played of my own
were again like nintendo or it had to be
on a pc
gotcha okay um so yeah
you know like call of duty yeah just
huge influence you know kind of on
gaming pop culture like everything at
the time it was truly true oh
truly truly ubiquitous yeah it was it
was transformative because um
you know i remember like i said just the
perk system and kill streaks and things
of that nature and
and it had just such an addicting nature
to it like you know when you start
playing it and then
you know you really respect the guys got
the special tags because you know they
reset their
their thing a couple of times and stuff
like that so there was there was there
was this prestige that where
you know yeah man it was a tie it was
definitely a movement at least
i know you didn't uh you were doing like
nintendo on pc but like in the console
space it was
extra transformative because for us us
peons
we had 60 frames for the first time
somebody like yo
this is crazy like you know you didn't
realize it at the time
you know because again he going from 30
but we knew something was different
something about the movement was more
fluid and stuff
so it's cool that you you mentioned uh
call of duty because it truly doesn't
get the credit
it deserves for being like a moment you
know as far as gaming and stuff
you think so you think so like i'll
defer to you i'll definitely
but let's go one thing i will say is i i
don't think it gets the credit it
deserves with regards to
staying like people people people look
at call of duty
and i feel like it gets a lot of hate
for like staying the same way
you know that's that's playing over yes
and i can see i can see that criticism
right yes so people kind of do what i
think
the evolution of just like you say kill
streaks
you know resetting your prestige you
know like certain game modes
that were like iconic game modes that
now you know
everybody has those game modes if you
have like a you know first-person
shooter
um so you know in some ways sure
uh it became a little stale but in a lot
of ways
like they were making just huge
evolutionary leaps transformative
in gameplay and also in game structure
you know reward structure in particular
uh that just
just completely influenced everything
today even though in in how we structure
our reward systems
um in fps
those same old gamepl you know if you
want that engagement that addictive
quality that cod had like you said that
the reward system and all these things
that they kind of pioneered in the space
because to be honest coming as an xbox
guy i remember when cod hit
and all my halo friends went to
and i was like what's going on and i'm
like all right and then i played it and
i'm like
okay i get it yep i get it yeah
absolutely
but you got e no so i wanted to kind of
touch on that time
between your gaming segments your bio
medical engineer that you are now and
your degree and like
obviously math and science is a big
thing for you and i appreciate that
because that's kind of the way my what
my mind works as well
um kind of nice but like how
what drew you to obviously your head was
in a book a lot
so i mean you know intellectual grown up
stuff like that what led you into the
field that you're in
and you know any cool stories i mean
biomedical engineer are you making like
what are you doing with that as well so
how'd you get into it and what do you
what are you doing with it
oh man my mouth is it's crazy because
you know everybody comes uh upon their
path in different ways right
um and i would say i don't know i don't
know
what the average person what time frame
where there's like oh this is what i'm
going to do
i remember specifically i was in
i was in eighth grade i was in eighth
grade
and for some reason my english teacher
my english teacher brought me the
prospect
uh because they knew i was strong in a
variety of different subjects but you
know i was strong in math and science of
course
um and it was um my black
uh english teacher um who just just
pushed me in a variety of different ways
he would give me comic books you know he
would give me extra three
he would um you know like send me stuff
with regards to like fellowships or like
scholarships et cetera et cetera
you know he was truly invested in seeing
me
move forward in whatever career i chose
because apparently he saw something in
me so
you know shout out to him for sure
awesome that's awesome but uh he's the
one that actually
like put me on to the field of
biomedical engineering
dealing with i already kind of knew i
was leaning towards engineering as far
as
you know me being kind of like a thinker
or a tinker um
but uh but it's you know as far as like
biomedical engineering i think it was
because at the time we had discussed
and for a while you know i was i was
gonna be pre-med
so i think that was i think that's where
the biomedical
the biological sciences aspect came in
and so it was kind of like a merger
between those two
those two interests um those interests
in you know
biological biomedical sciences um and
also engineering
as well um i think that the way that
my dad is a computer networking engineer
and uh i
picked up quite a bit from him kind of
sees the process of the world
um and i think that's the reason a large
part of the reason
why um you know engineering
engineering definitely means uh leads on
me quite a bit so
so i think that was that was kind of the
time frame that i knew i most likely
wanted to get environmental medical
engineering and i
kept on kind of like uh renewing my
interest in it by
you know fellowship scholarships
whatever whatever it is you know like i
did a bunch of stuff at duke when i was
younger i did a bunch of stuff at the
university of rochester
as far as research and things like that
and all those things you know just over
the years just reinforcing i gotta
really
enjoy the subject i really enjoy the
subject a lot and
on top of that there's just a lot of
versatility um to it
you don't necessarily have to be in a
lab in academia for example you know
doing research
you could be you know out of the private
sector doing a variety
which kind of fell in my lap was after i
finished up with grad school in
biomedical engineering
um i knew that i didn't want to go for
my phd i knew i didn't want to be in
academia
that's when i decided right there
because i was gonna i was initially
going for my phd
um but i cut out early got my masters um
and i was approached by the us
government us government ended up
uh putting my lab the opportunity to
become a patent examiner
you know long story short i ended up
doing that for nearly a decade what i
really enjoyed about it
um is uh you mean you basically
as a patent examiner you're reviewing um
people's inventive concepts right so it
comes up with something new that's kind
of cool
that's cutting edge particularly in your
field because i got pulled on as a
patent examiner specifically for
biomedical engineering
right um biomedical sciences biomedical
devices
particularly um somebody had been
something new or they think they
invented something new
then i'm gonna take a look at it i'm
gonna go through all all the research
all their filings et cetera et cetera
that i'm gonna look you know throughout
the entire world
right yeah but we have a search system
we look through this database throughout
yeah
exactly and we're trying to look for
somebody who's done that or done
something similar enough to it to the
point where we can say okay we just
pulled a bunch of things from
these areas and it's kind of obvious you
know you put that together
damn down here stealing stealing bars
okay
so or you know it's something brand new
and there's quite a few things that i
allowed you know
[Music]
and that ended up getting the the stamp
you know the allow and whatnot
um it was just it was it was um it is
something that ended up burning me out
because it's really intense work i mean
you're reading
all the time researching all the time
and on top of that you have
a quota you know that you have to meet
uh
you know every week and more importantly
every quarter and even more importantly
every year
so you know years and years and years of
that it just ended up kind of like
burning me out it's not as if i didn't
enjoy the work
but i mean it's as if it's it's as i
said before
um and that said now like i'm kind of
like a 0-100 person so therefore
uh you know i'm not about doing shoddy
work
right yep as you proceed up the ranks
you get
more you have more and more work to do
in less and less time
and i'm not about to do shoddy work
unfortunately i'm very meticulous very
detail-oriented
so it just ended up taking so much so
much time it became really stressful
because it was less and less time to do
the work that i really wanted the job
the really quality job that i really
wanted to do
um and so uh so ended up i ended up
dipping
you know and doing uh doing some more
similar work
on a um on a contract basis okay um
but uh but yeah i left the office maybe
i can't remember sometime like in the
mid
mid 2010s okay i remember at this point
but uh
but yeah but it was it was it's still
like fantastic because you're literally
looking at cutting edge
all the time scientific
stuff you know um every time you pick up
a new case
so you're you're just you you just you
learn thank you so much
so much like if my brain got massive
i can't fit through doors anymore
it could you know it couldn't fit
through doors anymore you're right it
got massive just because i was
reading and learning 24 7. if you didn't
understand something that you're reading
specific to that case
you reached out yeah i mean you reached
out for references
and reading over here because you had to
understand that case you had to
understand
like in order to allow it or uh or push
it off or push it off reject it you had
to literally understand exactly
what was going on in that case um and so
a lot of that
stuff fell within uh the realm
of my knowledge my knowledge base
especially as i got
more senior and it seemed more stuff but
a lot of stuff was like brand new [ __ ]
yeah where i mean like i said cutting
edge stuff and
uh i had to catch up i had to catch up
most of it yeah so
so i've got some dumb stuff some new
stuff but uh but yeah
it's it's a burnout and a lot of people
do burn out of there um
and it sounds like it's inevitable
depending on how long you stay if they
can put pushing you
faster and harder especially the way
your mind thinks it seems like it's just
bound to happen
yeah it's it's it's tough you know and
i'm not gonna say that i couldn't have
uh you know navigated that a little bit
better as well like a lot of people are
smart about
it too a little bit smarter they take a
little bit of time off right you know
where they're just like
because the office also provides you a
lot of opportunities to just be like hey
you know you need to dip out for like i
don't know three months six months or
something like that
get your [ __ ] together you know it's
fine but um
but you know uh me i'm just like no
i just need to get this case done you
know this attorney is waiting on me
i got you i guess and so uh you know
i don't regret i don't regret leaving
the office or whatnot i'm the type of
person that's always kind of looking
forward not not looking back
very much and the experiences that i've
been getting there the knowledge that i
gave
the connections the networking and
things like that are just invaluable to
where my blog you know the trajectory of
my life right now but
but yeah um i will say like one one last
thing
uh there's no there's nobody that better
understands patent law the law of
how to execute and prosecute um
patents then patent examiners even
attorneys just you know
just regular attorneys you know it's a
very niche area
gotcha very specific and so you become
an expert in that and that's pretty cool
but the second thing as well is i've
always had kind of like a very
level-headed
uh personality what i loved about like
going back and forth with attorneys is
there's no emotion to it
right now you know folks see how i
interact with folks online if we're on
the other
side of a argument
you know debate and whatever else it's
just like there's no there's no emotion
there's emotion to it yeah i'm
passionate about stuff but there's no
you know i don't i don't see you know
like i would say
that i don't see as an adversary as much
as i see
drewski as i'm picking his brain and i'm
trying to kind of
you know uh really
really try to like
hone my my perspective you know right
picking drewski's brain for example
it allows me to really really knock down
on
what i'm saying right
understand that different perspective as
well right and so
um you know that's what i mean by my
math and science background but also my
background with regards to law
um and legal arguments for like 10 years
uh you know it's really allowed me to
kind of just be open to different
perspectives
um it doesn't matter whether i'm right
or wrong whenever i come with
you know opinion i don't really have an
ego about it it's more so just about i
just
i'm just trying to learn i'm sure and
i'm just trying to
listen to these different perspectives
because everybody's got something you
know different saying
you know some more valuable you know to
the topic at hand than others but
um it's it's just always interesting to
hear on these different perspectives
and that's what kind of guides me to how
i interact with with
just everybody in my life oh that's dope
man because at the end of the day like i
said
it's it's a balance and you made some
great points you know just having that
objectivity
to even if it's someone who's point or
side you don't necessarily agree with
but to be able to hone in your specific
skills as to why
you feel the way you do and also sharpen
your points even further you know i mean
in regards to a specific argument and
stuff like that and that
again i like i like what you said
because a lot of people sadly
always put the emotion into it i noticed
and a lot of it you know we to help us
communicate even when even with me
on the other side of the fence or
certain things there's times he said
things and i'm just like you know what
over time i'm understanding where he's
at and i'm just trying to pick him like
help me understand why like
i have him explaining further and
further into more refined detail
and then you're like okay i get the core
essence of why he's here
right and then vice versa sometimes with
me he's like yo god why are you
so vehement you know and it's a that's a
great point and i wish more people
would do more of that as opposed to he's
an idiot
that ties into so much too and it's and
i've honestly hated
to see it recently and hates a strong
word but like dylan
how to talk to a community manager is
like a day or two ago and it's just like
oh and again it's people enjoy the veil
of the internet and their
jerks on kind of being able to hide the
anonymity of who they are
but on the other side it's like that
stuff you would never say to somebody's
face
if you can take two seconds and as you
know as physics said
put you get some perspective put
yourself in their shoes
think about all the things the dev the
community everybody's going through to
get where they are
right they didn't like just do this to
screw you over or be mad at you
or you know crap all over the one perk
that you like like that's not there
there's reasons behind all of us do we
always agree with them of course not but
of course would we like to know why it's
like we've said it i can't i
honestly have lost track of the number
of times we'd say in this podcast like i
would love to know
like the reasoning that goes behind this
decision
yes it's like i would love to be a fly
on the wall to understand like okay
so there they went through this this is
why they made this decision it's like
we know bungie is very data driven they
have all the numbers they go off all
that
type of stuff and it's why and then all
of a sudden you turn around and you're
just like
okay and that's the stuff that's like i
wish those are the questions i could ask
even if i could tell nobody just to like
put peace to my mind
just understand more as you said it's
like the perspective of doing the
research unfortunately
they don't always get they're not always
going to share everything and that's the
perk of a developer but it's just one of
those things we wish we could know
so yeah absolutely of course and let me
say this too that like i don't always
get it right as well it's not as if
you know like i'm infallible you know uh
emotion we're humans emotions gonna come
in from time to time you know whether it
be on my side or the other
and of course you got folks that are
trolls as well
you know it's just always things that
i'm thinking about
you know like hey convince me i might be
wrong convince me yes you convinced me
that's one thing you know another thing
if i am wrong you know for me to make
sure that i
if i'm really trying to be um a
constructive part of this community you
know to make sure that i said oh okay
all right cool
i accept that on the premise and that's
what i'm going to speak from now on
is exactly that but also you know when
emotion does come into it
it doesn't hurt just i mean how much
does that hurt two seconds
and that's definitely happened as well
that's definitely happening as well you
know folks generally do consider me
fairly level-headed or whatnot
doesn't mean you know like i haven't
i think that a large part of it really
is just folks coming back around
being humble and being like just like
that
yeah absolutely and i made some great
great friends like that and i'm truly
blessed that folks
you know give me the opportunity through
that yeah
no that's dope brother i mean again all
building
all great conversation and i love that
kind of stuff but um
what i was gonna ask you was now
actually you did that transition and
you got out of that the hardcore level
of just that
the patent life so to speak and my thing
now is that then you transition but like
how did you
incorporate now content creation like i
want to get to that but like
how did that happen because you seemed
so razor focused
in what you were doing you know what i
mean and i just want to know how that
part
came was it specifically now
transitioning to destiny that that
opened it up or was it something else
that kind of brought the content
creation aspect out of you
yeah uh everything for me in my life has
been like just
organic like i just kind of like just
flow with
whatever for them you know what i'm
saying like i already said
with it brother that's the person you
know like i'm
never like so for better for worse
i'm never like man i really need to be
focused on like a career like
like a like a like a i don't know a
regular stereotypical career i didn't
even
write about my 401k you know i'm just
like
i really enjoy this right now and i see
a way to monetize it
um you know i'm gonna you know and i see
that there's organic growth that is
happening right now and that i can
continue to double down on
and will continue to happen if i end up
doing that and doing that at a high
level
um and i see it and when i see it i just
i just
i just try to go for it whether that
ends up translating into
success or not uh
we will remain to see or remain to be
seen or whatnot but
i i've been looking up my life that if i
really really truly double down and
laser focus on something and generally
it manifests in a way that um not only
allows me to live
um but also um you know it's in a way
that
really does like fulfill me and is is
alone
along the uh i guess like
in destination of what i you know what i
was going for you know so
uh as far as like conte creation you
know like i finished up at the office i
was still doing you know a decent amount
of
contract work which i still do from like
time to time
um and uh i was playing a decent amount
of destiny my brother got me into
destiny because he was overseas
um he was overseas and also he was in a
different state at certain points of
time he was just like y'all want
something to be able to play with you
and hang out even though you know like
uh you're not right next door to me
and so sarah played this he's the one
that got me hooked thank you
shout out to the bro shout out
and so uh he stopped playing because he
just got busy with life and whatnot
i kept playing and i'm a very
competitive individual
i
you know above average level nothing
even in comparison to where my standing
is in destiny now
i was never so improvement focused in
whatever game i was playing as i am in
destiny now
it was above average for sure um and uh
so when i came to destiny you know like
the those same cogs were turning with
regards to the competitive nature of pvp
so of course you know i was planning
this amount of pve to kind of like ease
into it with my brother and things along
that line but
uh even when he ended up dipping i found
pvp and i found
really enjoyable um and uh you know i
started making friends through there and
then they suck you in with trials
and so then you know i started taking
playing pvp at a relatively high level a
little more seriously
like i said competitive always been
improvement focused on no matter what i
do
hobbies or otherwise um as far as
content creation goes
i kind of just like you know how i've
explained it before
when i moved over to pc when i moved
over to pc
um that's where kind of like my
community
my community started to grow just in
general and it grew out of the fact that
when i came over to pc i didn't i didn't
know anybody
hmm most of my plan didn't come over i
didn't know anybody so i know that well
i know that well
he he got me over here over here
you know especially during a period of
time where skill-based matchmaking was
which was pretty pretty pretty tough
pretty tough
during year one okay so started
connecting with a bunch of different
people
had my discord server um with like
hundreds of people in it
um and uh that's where you know my
community started even though at that
time i didn't necessarily think of it as
a community i just thought of it as a
group of friends you know that i could
pull in and play with
uh whenever i needed somebody to play
with i'm a very social gamer as well
and so then i started streaming just to
as kind of an extension of that
community to so that even when i wasn't
playing with the people that i now
became friends with i could still hang
out with them
right no so that's how i transitioned
from the discord and playing with people
playing with friends
um to then you know streaming it was
just about hanging out with my friends
even if i didn't have the opportunity to
actually be playing a game with them
right then and there
um and you know that's where kind of
like content creation
started with me i didn't think of twitch
as content creation at that point for
sure
um but then you know as i saw
a way to start monetizing that time um
that's when i started to focus
a little bit more on content that's when
i started to focus a little bit more on
what is this concept of community
through content creation
as well um and that's when i started
kind of doubling down
on both of those things kind of trying
to um
you know progressively improve the
quality of both of those things
community and content creation so
yeah then i went full-time last year
around like uh march or april and we've
been doing it
non-stop full-time since you know right
now where i am with content creation is
i'm trying to
really hone that up just about figuring
out my niche
my niche you know um and i'm trying to
figure out
okay now how am i going to double down
on that niche
and further monetize that niche for
growth right uh
so yeah you know just certain stages but
for me it's always about kind of just
like organic growth it's always about
organic community it's always about
connecting with folks
making friends allowing other folks to
meet um
you know my friends because quality
surrounds itself equality and so i
like my friends to make you know friends
with each other and um whether i'm there
or not so
yeah love it man love what i'm hearing
man yeah great
great thing and i love the community
building aspect
and yeah and that part is just really
cool and i think you said it
before in one of your posts on bungie by
the way which
you were spotlighted very very coolly by
the way
yeah salute salute and um yeah man i
think like i said
it it's so cool because what you said
kind of is what resonates with me i just
feel like it
look we know we love destiny here but it
truly
is one of the best communities i've ever
been a part of you know in gaming and it
again this this man here like again i
met because of this game and we have
this friendship because of this game and
it it's so important so salute to you
for for what you're doing in that space
because
and having that dialogue you know i saw
you you know you had a couple pedals a
lot about pvp
god you had a nomad in there tassie
comfy like it was a cool
discussion and i was just like yo this
is cool and i mean even though everybody
some people had different viewpoints
it's just
all you guys coming together and
thinking about how to improve especially
my beloved pvp which i'm always a fan of
those discussions sir
yeah i just had to shout you out on that
but yeah salute to you all that that's
dope
i could blow over it but i'm gonna eat
talk because i no i mean that's that's
why we haven't
years for one just like if i if i go it
would be four hours we would we try to
keep the contest
you're like we gotta let this uh this
man sleep or read or
whatever
no but i mean that's kind of one of the
things especially lately why i was like
perfect time
to get you on is some of the stuff that
we've had recently with regards to
sandbox changes
some of um you know the threads that
you've had on twitter talking about
things like quick draw and like your
thoughts about it the way you play
uh one of your recent highlights that
was literally only possible you said
mostly because of quick draw and stuff
like some of the changes that are there
and it's i'm kind of curious to see just
where your thoughts are
for you know where things are head in
the world pvp where it's at right now
and just kind of your thoughts about
sandbox and destiny and is there
anything for like where it is right now
that you're liking so far and like
direction you see and
what are like you know changes that you
would like to see
for the game when we're looking at like
season 14 or
is there something at which queen that
you're like i really just i kind of need
something
to see something like that here i have
one of those for me but i want to ask
you that's why
oh man this is a huge question it's a
huge question
also because we've got this this looming
backdrop
of an actual competitive pvp right here
and that just changed the game right i
mean
we've kind of known about it a little
bit you know but
i think that posts uh by destiny news
net and by tassie and tess has been
following it as well of course
you know kind of changes the context of
the conversation quite a bit
because if bungie you know put to put it
simply if budgie is working on that
you know that's where they're trying to
funnel the competitive aspect of their
game
and then we need to think a little bit
differently about well what does that
mean for this game
this game you know that they what do
they want the direction for this game to
be
you know in the context of this whole
competitive backdrop
you know does that mean that then
destiny's gonna be basically like
just fun is it just a fun game to put it
simply you know it's the pvc supposed to
be just fun
and we're going to usher as many
competitive folks over here
you know so therefore we want the skill
gap to be relatively small here
you know like nothing nothing crazy but
of course we're going to usher all the
folks who really truly
um enjoy like a sizable skill gap
um we're gonna push them over to our
competitive game
right so that's that's one thing that
you know
kind of sticks in my mind when i'm
talking about you know
kind of sandbox changes um and
you know whether those sandbox changes
specifically narrow
whether i'm thinking it'll narrow or
expand the skill gap
um that's one thing
second thing is
something that i like and something that
folks need to continue to keep in mind
this is this is a uh you know how like
this is 70 years of destiny right yeah
seven years in 2014 right
seven years of destiny right we have
some some people who are real nice
you know pvp wise real nice you got to
keep that in mind they're people that
have been playing since
the beta oh like i only started playing
in in and taking king and this is why
you got some people that have been
playing since the beta
my point is
there's a sizable skill gap in destiny
right now
by no other fault of
than just the fact that people just been
playing for a long last time
right you know and bungie's trying to
temper that a little bit because that's
that's that's a proven prohibitive
there's a new folks coming in
right you know all the way back here
whatever what i've heard and
this is why i love kind of like um
ingratiating myself to some degree uh
with the more casual bass is because
then
okay they'll share some of their
perspectives with me
you know coming from a community where
you know the sweat community the the the
higher skill level
we haven't always like treated you know
casuals you know very very kindly
good point yeah
physics
i can understand why there's there's
some animosity towards that
of course of course and so um i love it
when
uh folks share those different
perspectives um with me
uh from their gameplay experience and
one thing that i continue to hear
is that uh this the the the
what's the word that i'm looking for um
the learning curve learning from curve
for coming into pvp right now especially
if you're trying to get into
even just a little bit of comp just a
little bit of charles you know like
but even in quick play you know
it's just really smashed really strong
boys getting smashed
yeah it doesn't take long yeah to walk
in and be
i and just realize i'm outclassed like
very very quickly
and and that's this is this is the thing
too you know that
i've told folks it's just like when
you're out class by a certain degree
when the skill gap between you
and the next person or even just the
average person is so great
there's no learning experience right yep
you don't you don't understand what's
going on to the point where you can
change something
you know for improvement in that
situation you know what you don't
understand there's so
many different it's overwhelming
overwhelming
and uh and it's we've been sitting here
about seven years
we've said it for seven years so purely
off of the fact that
you know folks have just been playing
this game for so long it's
i guess my point is the direction that i
do like
that i do think that bungie is taking
with destiny and what they
truly do realize is this right here and
the fact that they need to continue to
make the game as accessible as possible
to new folks coming in
you know especially folks that want to
get involved pvp because otherwise
our population our base is going to
continue to shrink my man
folks when folks are in pvp just in
quick play and they just [ __ ] it on the
entire time you can't understand
what's going on what to do differently
in order to correct that
you know so um you know i can of course
you know like switch off and you know
evolve this conversation into
what i you know my channel and how um
it's very improvement focused and
community customs on sundays
2 p.m eastern that's right plug it back
up get them done
there are no shameless plugs on this
let's go
sir perfect segway
but i'm just i'm just saying you know
like um
it's something i think that's truly on
their mind it's something that i try to
keep in mind whatever i'm having for
example these quick draw conversations
uh where people are getting flipped on
with the shotgun and they don't really
know how to respond they don't really
know how to combat that
they're they're you know i can tell you
your your positioning is bad but
how do you really change that if you
just come into the game you know like
you don't
really process like how to change
you know the engagement distance so so
basically we're having this
relatively high level conversation and i
need to back it down a little bit and be
like
well okay all right well you probably
don't even know how to change your
engagement
distance to even combat that you don't
even know what i'm talking about so
i don't know you know it's um
sometimes when i'm having these
conversations online i try to pull
myself back and i'm just like a lot of
people don't even understand what you're
talking about
right right you know a lot of people are
just trying to play games already a lot
of people aren't trying to necessarily
improve they're just out there just
trying to hang out
right right with the grenade launcher
every once in a while just have some fun
drag out um it's it's a it's a really
tough
bounce this is what i say it's a really
tough balance for bungie and i do
not take that for granted it is an
extremely tough balance and it just that
that tough balance that
that difficulty just comes from so many
different areas i feel like a lot of
people don't even consider
yeah man you made again phenomenal
points i think that
that's the that's the that's always
going to be the struggle for them you
know
because again i don't again i don't have
the percentages offhand but let's just
say that
the sweat community represents this you
know 15 to 20
or whatever it is and then you have this
casual base that
again they may want to try trials for
the first time
and see what that experience is about
and
their first experience is so utterly
demoralizing
that they have no idea what went wrong
and then the first inclination
internally is like well i'm done i'm not
i'm not staying here like everyone gets
smashed
so again you i know us i'm not the
hardcore community but i'm not above
maybe average community but what what i
realized is that
that is so important because what ends
up happening if that base
leaves right and the pool gets so much
smaller
then the the sweats are playing each
other and getting frustrated because
every match is super sweaty so it's just
this weird dichotomy that they have to
solve but
what i wanted to transition is into what
we were talking as far as the uh this
new potential
pvp bungee ip thing right so
the question becomes that i want to
bring it to both of you
is that obviously we're seeing that this
thing's development we see a job posting
on
you know they're talking about it it
almost sounds esportsy
a little bit you know it it we're
getting into this room so now that we're
knowing
that this is going to be a focus from
them maybe resource wise
you know how do you then transition that
apply that to
where destiny's pvp is now and our
frustration with it
do we say hey well they're working on
this
and i'm gonna give them a pass because
of it or is it a situation where like
like how do you process
this information now coming out to you
that they are working on a dedicated
pvp kind of a game in relation to
relation to destiny's pvp if you know
what i mean
currently right now for me you know like
for me it's kind of like a tough love
thing you know it's just like um
like you have like you have this game
right here like i don't care whether
you're working on a new ip or not
i don't care whether you're working on
new ip or not if you tell me now
this is you this is your business this
is your game you still have millions of
people that are playing
okay so it's just like you can't tell me
that
you know we don't have the resources for
this um
we don't have the resources for this in
bungie or whatnot because we got this
other ip going on over here
you can't really tell me that you know
as someone that plays like several times
a week because it's just like well
you didn't think about that beforehand
you know you know
you don't have the resources to split
okay let's see where we're going for the
game that is live right now that people
continue to play money
you know for like every single day in
your report store you know it's just
like
um i don't really go for i don't really
go for her
i don't really go for that i want to go
for that now what i will say without
what i will go for is if bungie is very
transparent about the direction
of the game with first pvp because we
have this other ip going over here
look people look we got this other ip
it's about to be esports
dedicated servers get ready for that oh
god can you imagine
understanding this honestly i see this
that
the way that we're trying to work
destiny specifically is destiny's not
we're not trying to make it any degree
of competitive
right you know like we're not going to
make any degree or competitive our our
goal with destiny you know with with
this with this ip
right here is that we're trying to make
it as successful as accessible as
possible
as possible we're trying to get this
population up you know
we're trying to make this a true little
shooter and not
something you know that right yeah you
know you seem to say like
we're not trying to make it anything you
know any particular semblance of
competitive right
you know we're trying to keep trials
there we're trying to keep you know cop
there what not we might just completely
take cop out of the mix
you know so that people don't even see
like the competitive aspect in that
particular realm
because we're not even doing anything
with comp anyway in the same way for
like a minute there's no real rewards
there
but my point is i just want to bungee
just tell me
just tell me what the direction is you
tell me what the direction is
therefore my expectations revolve around
what you tell me
and therefore i'm not going to be
disappointed over here
something that is counter to my
expectations just give me some
expectations thank you
that's all i'm saying you hear what you
do with your hair
it's your game in the end i might be
passionate about something you know but
i don't care what you do with your game
because i understand it's your game
and i can play it if i want to play it
and i cannot play it if i don't want to
play it but just
tell me exactly what
i didn't make that decision so i'm not
sitting on the fence
literally no brother you said it that
and i'll give it back to you i know i
mean i had to get this off
but it's like that's the source of
frustration because again
literally what you said is what i've
been preaching which is like okay
as long as we know what's going on as
long as we
understand you communicate to us why
there hasn't been any
pvp maps and god knows why there's been
no
you know focus on the structure why
improvements are taking so long
why pv the pvp community feels so
neglected
and for a person like myself who
literally fell in love with this mode
to not see any attention to it and then
on the flip side when you look at pve
and you look at sandbox changes you look
at all these things and you see
all the attention go one-sided for a
season
you know multiple seasons and like
myself like yourself like
i love trials and it hurts me when i i
see it sometimes in the state it is and
and you just see one like example when
they put the messenger in with a
desperado per and you see people
rush to actually play it now you see the
little things where the incentive is you
know
being incentivized to play stuff and
comp it really goes to show you like
okay
talk to us because when you do these
things you know you see that the the
community is engaged and i'll give it to
e
in in reference to the question um about
this new multiplayer quote unquote new
ip
that's pvp focus like when when this
news came across your table with tassie
cause you don't want to put it up
in the dm like what was your thought
process now like
are you like yo okay but like what
happens with destiny
or you like you know like where are you
at whitney i'm very curious this is
this is cool information that came out
uh
i mean it would make a lot of it makes a
lot of sense but also what tony
physics what i'm gonna call you one of
those or the other i don't know which
one's gonna come out um
the biggest thing as you said first is
we would like to know
the direction long term and they've
given us a glimpse of the fact that we
have three and a half years
of this saga there's likely going to
be more of destiny after that we don't
know
i've been wondering honestly for a long
time how long and i've had discussions
with my chat about the same thing is
how long do they even keep up with you
know now
past gen consoles how long are you gonna
maintain ps4s and xbox ones they're
literally eight years old nine years old
10 years old when do you stop supporting
that platform so that doesn't hold you
back theoretically to do things like
take weapons and have another perk be a
possibility or have another
perk slot or when we're at the capacity
now
we talked about this last time or the
time before the legendary literally can
only have so many perks active at the
same time because systematically if
there's another one
the game breaks and something doesn't
function
that's a very very very deep issue to
how the game is built like structurally
fundamentally the code
it's a very deep issue if something's at
that level
so for them to make those type of
changes it's either a deep system rework
and that's something maybe they can do
over the next few years
are we looking out to a destiny 3
destiny universe whatever that thing's
going to be called
to see bigger changes like that and then
this now
goes to the other side of okay so what
are the next three and a half years are
going to be like is what this
always takes me back to what are we
going to look at for
armor sets for example that's when i
always after playing out writers
especially
yeah especially that's just like
eye-opening like dude this is amazing
craziness going on
can i have even a little in destiny
sometimes on the pve side especially
like pvp
it's hard because they're always walking
that delicate line of have fun in the
game but we got to make sure stuff isn't
completely busted
when i walk into a pvp match otherwise
it's just not fun in a lot of ways
so i get that's a delicate line but on
the other side hey if i go do raids or
if i go to do strikes or there's set
bonuses
if i can't have set bonuses because
there's technical limitations like i
fall down a rabbit hole really fast when
i think about the next couple of years
about this
but this one on turn for the other side
a lot of like the community is pvp
focused
you've got a lot of streamers that do
weekend you know trial streams you've
got community helps like our man right
here
um you ascended nomad you've got people
that just enjoy pvp more because
they may jump on for the story on
tuesday do a couple of quests but why do
they play the rest of the week
right if they don't care about checking
a couple triumph boxes it's pvp
they love the competition and that type
of thing and that's the side of your
like okay so
there's a room and this is a point where
if the rumor is out there it's on bungie
to try and address it sooner than later
because the longer that rumor festers
the longer people
on either side of the equation of hey is
pvp going to be amazing if we get rid of
if all the pvp people go over there is
the pve destiny gonna be something i
hope for
well we don't know if they don't tell us
on the other side of the pvp people like
i might as well just like set this thing
down for a little while wait for this
other pvp like
those are the things if you start
digging farther into the future
that this other prospect of a pvp
competitive not trying to balance 10 000
different options in one match type game
if they can really hone down on you know
your dmrs and stuff like more of a halo
set weapons something along those lines
for a set game that's competitive in
esports level
what does that do to your game well
that's the question of like how long is
it
how how far reaching are those effects
into the future
is the next two or three years of
development that the game they won up by
2025 which that number keeps coming up
if it comes out in 2025 is the next
three years of pvp really still going to
be the same like this is comp
going to continue to slowly fall to the
wayside good and we're never going to
see anything like a ladder system
is trials ever going to see something
like dedicated servers
it's like pc is going to be cheated but
then you see people like jump on satan
and be like outside of a little input
lag
you know trials on stadium is one of
those things people like it's the
cleanest place to play if you can deal
with a little input lag and it's like
that's one of those when you're like
that hurts a little bit if there's no
plan to do that
because the future prospects are where
their attention is
and it comes back to the state of the
game's engine systems or otherwise
is it too much for them to fix so they
have to move forward
so like i mean that's a long-winded
rambling answer but i mean that's one of
those to where it's
i it honestly makes me wonder more about
what the future
next couple of years are going to be
like as we get to the future like i'm
excited about this other pvp game from
bungie i'm sure it's going to be hella
fantastic like you know their
their feel of every gun and bullet that
comes out of your gun is amazing
i don't expect that to be different in
what comes in the future
but again how what's the journey to get
there i guess that's my question
no question because i gave into this
article late and i want to
be clear um it's saying bungie's new and
unannounced ip franchise to feature
competitive pvp multiplayer with esports
so from my understanding right correct
me from the
the secret code name of this ip
supposedly allegedly was matter
is this going to be an additional
component of matter or is
matter just for what we're hearing this
pvp razor focus kind of new ip
i guess it's my question is it you know
is it a title my from
my understanding the stating of
something being developed in parallel
matter is one thing maybe this pvp focus
thing that they're still working on
and then something else in the destiny
universe may evoke there's going to be
two separate
two ips anyway maybe a destiny three or
some future of the destiny but then i
matters of code name whether it's this
or the future of destiny
right it's separate but like when they
say in parallel people are like oh is it
in the destiny universe i'm like
no like developed at the same time what
they're talking about
right so that's what at least the way i
read that that's good that i understand
it as well
okay that was my question yeah it's
gonna be interesting
and and like i said physics said it best
like the key is you know
while that's happening and we know this
now the information is out
you know the key is gonna be charting
the next three years with destiny
how is the focus there how is that
approach there because like physics says
to be honest like
in fairness to the people who still play
this ip they don't really care about
that
like like it's what are you doing about
this current game now and to fix pvp now
we know shout out to the homie that that
took over on from luke smith that it's
kind of in that role now
justin um thurman like that i have to
get his name is it blackberry i forget
his name
oh jordan yeah those two are kind of
like right yeah
because i did didn't we i mean we we
know the the the feeling at the studio
is very they're very passionate right
now that you're seeing the bungee tweets
yeah like you know
so in bungie like yeah totally they're
feeling good right so i think it's up to
them now when we used to get our
quarterly you know luke smith state of
the game kind of a situation right
so i'm very curious to see when we get
that
in the space of the future when it comes
to destiny and we do know
about these projects as well but how
razor focus will destiny be
attended to that especially the pvp
scene that's good with the question well
i mean when the state of the game comes
out and they don't mention
very much about pvp outside of trials
like
right new maps new like there's not a
lot of mention with regards to the state
of pvp
or like is there any future plans to as
you said put
anything into comp none of that is
mentioned in the state of the game so
again you have to
that just leads to more questions and
worry as opposed to
the transparency at least a little bit
be like hey we are working on
you know a deep dive into the comp
system we'll let you guys know in a
couple months once we have some of the
details
nothing like zero at this point and
that's what i think leaves a whole lot
of people
especially the crucible focus community
very unsettled yeah and a really good
example of that really good example is
cheap
right really good example of that shoot
it's just like
we go we can take a really deep dive
into this
right it's just like look we don't know
what's going on with the answer
but they let us know they're working on
it they let us know they're actually
working on it
they acknowledged it and they let us
know they're working on it and on top of
that these small
little things that they do you know dmg
comes out every once in a while just
like yo
you know make sure you send me this make
sure you send me that you know we taking
care of this every once in a while
you'll see somebody get banned
specifically on stream
or something along that line you know so
we know that there's some some things
kind of happening in the background
imaginations right right um look
i'm really frustrated cheating i'm
really incredibly frustrated with each
other but just that little bit just that
little bit
been letting us know they're working on
it and you know every once in a while
i'm acknowledging this and that
is helpful that's what do you know how
helpful it would be if we got even more
transparent if we got
even more like updates because it's been
a minute since cosmos enough that um
that tweet with regards to the answer to
the important answer it's been a long
time way more than three months
you know so again my point is
and the same i'll leave it right back
around you know when i was i'm saying
dakar was just like
look a lot of this stuff
you know a lot of the frustration in the
community you know and i'm glad they
started to kind of tap into this a
little bit a lot of this frustration
that
you know just talk to us talk to us and
set some expectations page sets
mechanics if you see something rumbling
in the community don't let it fester
just like he said
don't let it fester even it like just
even the smallest thing can start to
just blow up dmt right now
you know dead man's tail i started
fester a little bit because
the ease of use is so high specifically
on pc i don't know how it is
on console because i'm not there but
specifically on pc the
the ease of use is so high that folks
are having an issue with them taking an
issue don't let that fester
right address it even we're taking a
look at it take a look at it yeah
we'll get back to you we'll collect some
more data last night before you maybe in
like a month
you know up and a half or something like
that and then we'll see if it needs
something kind of like tone back or
whatever else you know
just talk just don't let it fast
transparency uh goes a long way with
kind of easing the frustration and
allowing me to sit back and just wait
because some people were just like uh
you know they feel like oh man you know
like tony for example or
this person over here they're gonna
complain you know it doesn't matter what
it is
i'm not gonna get to this heightened
frustrated level to the point where i
feel the need to actually say something
on twitter about it
whatever else platforms you know i'm not
gonna get to that level quite as quickly
if
i feel like bungie's listening i feel
like he's actually
you know yeah give me give me something
break let me show you
something it's that acknowledgement
right like you said it was almost like i
remember when arbales was running wild
for a little bit
and it's just like okay we see it you
know what i'm saying
or we're looking at you 600 rpm you know
some autos you know what's that we see
it
once i i'm the same way with your
physics like once i
see that i'm cool you're not going to
get the the crazy wild out tweet and
going in on the developer and y'all what
the hell you ain't gonna get that i'ma
chill
because i know you on it but when like
you said there was that period
where cheating was so loose that the
cheetahs were so
brazen and
do you see it and it was silenced during
that period
and and it was so frustrating and it it
really broke my heart because i'm like
yo i want to love this game in this mode
and you're not even
talking you're acting like nothing's
going on and they know what's going on
but
again it's the transparency and i don't
know if if it's a thing where
because they feel that they can't reach
a realistic deliverable
that they don't want to talk about it
but it's still not a good process to not
be transparent because
once that frustration like you said gets
to that point and then twitter
there's no stopping
[Music]
and we had some trouble
the child's help we've been having some
trouble
i put on that gun and we got like three
four or five cards done back to back
shooting that
about that meta though like 600 rpms
were so popular like
one thing i've heard from listening to a
lot of people like firing range and a
lot of the people that
aren't too thrilled with the current
meta being so ability heavy and not
gun heavy like when the 600 rpms were
active it was a lot of guns and little
less of the other stuff oh yeah
oh for sure let me ask a quick question
i know we're going over with the surge i
think we gotta move over but i have to
ask
physics this like from a pvp what was
like
you know i always call it like the the
reign of this or the like it was a meta
that was like yo like i remember like
lord of wolves how to run
like give me some betters that would
either already see i already see what
the question's doing yeah you already
know where i'm going so
the the matters that you couldn't stand
because it was like a feared matter or a
meditation like yo i
liked when this was really like give me
some of that
let's go let's go all right here we go
here we go
uh we started with the meta that we'll
start with the meta that i love
that you love let's go rash
because you think max range is going to
do something and i'm gonna have
stability on my [ __ ] and i'm gonna give
you the gun
and over again some titans these titans
come out
you know and these titans they're just
like oh i can put i can prime right now
the shotgun they put on their max range
full boarded spare rashes
then they probably spared the [ __ ]
lord of wolves and you knew
they knew i was in the game
when i saw you at the back i had to
backstab
i love spare benders uh forsaken when it
first came out with
these spades of course as well before
not forgotten started taking over
um like those are probably my two
favorite menace because they were
they were truly like hand cannon uh
my go figure and i finally took that
away yeah don't get me wrong i love you
i
[Music]
i still have one hold on i know he can't
get rid of it
i know he ain't get rid of it damn dad
oh my god damn dad
posted he always got that what was that
the black armory one that you had too
what was that one
i never got the god roll on that furnace
i never got the glad roll
mine was literally just outlaw rampage
but it was ricochet
it was a long zoom scope so it was like
a dusk scope perfect
for you master work uh it was just a
range masterwork as well
so that was nice
on that one keep in mind that was before
the ricochet round nerf yeah
the zoom factor from there
on that map but then folks quickly learn
you know oh you just gotta have a really
nice pulse
[Music]
so flip side now the most notorious
you were disgusted matter disgusting
just this a completely dishonest meta
that's completely dishonest which one
sniper matter sniper meta one percent
and
it was it was even worse
because on pc that's when like the
cheating started getting like
rampant yeah raising whole clans started
popping up of cheaters everybody knew
they were cheaters what was the sniper
what's his name
it didn't matter where you literally and
the crazy thing is
you know soft paintbot existed and i
called
soft aimbot because it's not really
cheating it's just like snipers were so
easy
that and the flinch pattern was so
um we'll call it just easy yeah the
flesh pattern was so easy i mean
basically if you've seen the videos you
literally tap them like once or twice
and it pops
to your head to your head it's in a
flush of a way yes
it doesn't pop it up it literally clicks
back to your head so even
if you're just on the head to begin with
it flinches
to your head it's insane it's insane so
so it's just like uh that matter right
there because i am so
primary focused especially with my hand
cannon you know like the amount of times
i to tap somebody to the head and
whether it was a cheater or whether it's
just somebody legit
because of the flinch the flinch pattern
it would just click right to my head and
then i'd be dead
was that just like that beloved was that
the beloved though
yeah when you literally went into even
just a sixes match and you just saw
scopes after school
[Laughter]
nobody wanted to primary man i'm sitting
here like
just shining my shoes
i don't know i don't know i don't know
jimmy jimmy billy jimmy
just maybe maybe maybe maybe
[Music]
[Music]
and that is the origin also of the like
when i started calling people cowards
as well is when folks just look
primarily
salute to physics for being messy
around for those fights respect respect
oh that's sorry for the tangent
i had to get that question though that's
right
i don't get these conversations a lot it
was good to hear the same
level of frustration that i had i mean
that's one of those
when you go through seven years of
destiny you've lived through
like the thorn the you know the glowing
green screen thorn you've been through
those times you've been through laser
tag you've been through
all of those moments where you're like
yeah stuff was a little busted for a
little while
and we've been through all of these
waves but also as
it's just one of those things how long
some of them last like
the one-eyed mask meta oh
that one lasted like i don't know of a
whole lot of people that were like oh no
that's totally fine like
the whole twitter that i follow was like
yeah this is broken for a year
and then finally it comes around and
every so often you're like
i know you guys have a lot of data and i
know you guys read the community
and then there's reddit and twitter
still
those are some of the times when you
have to wonder what is taking
so long and sometimes they've said the
technicality of like well if we do this
one thing it's gonna break six others
and like completely nerf it into the
ground
but then sometimes they'll literally
gray out something because it's so
busted so i always wonder again comes
back all the way around
to love to be a fly on the wall for some
of the decisions sometimes because some
things last a while
like rockets took a year to get a buff
versus on the other side
you know you've got stuff in pvp that'll
get turned off in like a day
you know swords weren't that long you
really weren't here like they weren't
that long
you're right i think this words i mean
correct me if i'm wrong
you know but i feel like swords were
like
likely the most effective heavy that
we've seen in destiny 2 like period
i'm just just the most effective we're
not talking about just what boston we're
talking about just across the effect
literally allowed swords and the ports
that we have on swords like literally
allowed folks
to more easily solo things
absolutely you know absolutely so to see
those nerf likes so
soon i'm sure it was based on usage
numbers since they were you know since
they're so strong across like d2
um when they became uh prevalent i'm
sure those useless numbers said
oh okay we probably need to turn this
back but i would have liked to have seen
this for like a little bit longer
because me too
even me as a pvp player not even like a
pve i was
i was really enjoying like going in and
trying to solo some [ __ ]
because i knew i had a really strong
tool that would allow me to um
to take down champions absolutely oh
yeah i mean i've gone through and done
countless videos of soloing lost sectors
and stuff that's
my usual guidance is trying to solo
stuff generally so when you have
something
a lot of the times especially and it's
been a weird thing from destiny 1 to
destiny 2 for me
is i generally don't feel like i have
enough dps as one player
and that's one of those things and i'm
granted esoteric will prove me wrong
every time with a hand tied behind his
back but he's just the monster
no that's not human he's not human
it's an android absolutely yeah but
that's just one of those two
the sword was a nice i like the
risk-reward
aspect of it and i think when it comes
to the boss fights and getting in there
whether it was you know pit of heresy
you're like i gotta be in there
but i also know i have to build
specifically and that's why i like that
one
sword perk that was on an artifact where
if you're wearing a sword and you
equip the sword you're going to take a
little less damage
like wow yeah pass a guard yeah so it's
like when you're up close and i'm
sitting there wailing on the pit of
heresy's old mac boss
and this one exploded thrall makes it
through my bubble of blindness and he
like blows up next to me
i'm not instantly gonna get nuked for
that one like just crap moment
and it was that but it was a but again
you can't run anything else when that
happens you're using that like six or
seven to your thing
you get to play and that's one of those
little builds i got to enjoy and it just
seems
swords got nerfed once and then now with
lament and then a couple more times
it was a fun style and it's one of those
things you see come into a game like
destiny i'm like
we had him in d1 but we only had exotics
so i'm like legendary swords let's see
how they do and they actually ended up
being fun
and unfortunately now i think the fun
they're they're pulling away from it
again and i've heard some people in my
chat just say
you know it's like can you stop stealing
my fun now that's a
balancing thing sometimes but it's like
it's a phrasing
when you again experience something like
outriders like it is so brokenly fun
of how many things can be going on but
it's also the way they scale and manage
it still feels like they make you
powerful enough to
barely handle all the stuff they throw
at you and i kind of enjoy that balance
of like being on the brink of dying half
the time
and the sword was always that kind of
risk reward jump in and did it did i get
the smash can i get back it like
those moments were fun and it's like
when you're a little farther away you're
just shooting a hand cannon a boss it
doesn't feel like it does anything
and that's kind of when you feel like
you're bid in the moment so yeah swords
are fun and i'm
with you that i'm sad i see him go yeah
absolutely yeah and i think
also keep in mind as well like we got we
got the sword we got the fun
you know and now we might be back to
like rockets just sitting back
too so i mean some of it is kind of just
like you know
we got to experience that high right
right really getting in the fight
really getting engagement like deep in
high risk high report exactly what you
said
and and now we're back to you know like
the best dps is kind of like sitting
back
you know so it's snipe auto rocket it's
not an easy bounce
it's not easy you know like reward
balance
you know for budget to manage i
certainly don't want to make it seem
like oh man this is easy
all you got to do is yeah i'm not saying
that you know but all i am saying is
you know i would like to see like swords
you know hang in there
outside of of course pvp we got the
world of uh
guardian games yes not too far away
around the corner
before i even go into what's coming
before we knew about any changes you
guys knew it was coming on the calendar
what were your thoughts going into this
pre-announcement you guys like hey
guardian games is coming back you're
like i'm just going to be in trials on
the weekends what's guardian games like
where were you on the spectrum of
excitement for guardian games before we
got the news of what's coming
physics but you got whatever yeah uh you
know
guardian games is definitely one of
those activities for a pvp main right i
mean
it's for me i'm just like whatever i
mean that's basically that's basically
what i meant with it um
because i'm not going to spend a lot of
my
time in activity in the activities that
um like okay so if i was to contribute
for example
like my contribution would have to be
pretty squarely in line with the
activities that i
already had already engaged right
considering guardian games
there's not a lot of overlap you know
like the activities that contribute
towards for example hunters winning or
something like that
it's not as if i'm gonna be in those
activities engaging
in those specific you know points or
whatever else um
you know very often i have to actually
go out of my way to do that
with my schedule i'm not really not
really going to be doing that basically
so it's not to say that i don't uh enjoy
it as an activity and i
think it's worth a lot of years i do
definitely think that it does i think
it's
particularly whimsical uh yeah the
nature of titans
and how they just they just want to win
like
shout out to the titans titans man i'm
telling you these days there's nothing
in destiny that cracks me up more than
like titans
they just i don't know it's just
something about something special about
the personalities of the folks that play
titan as a name
it's just i love it it's endearing
let's
is
[Music]
it's one of those activities for me
where you know i enjoy kind of like
sitting back and
looking to see looking in and seeing
yeah you know what's going on with it
but not something that's uh you know
necessarily actively engaging
you you're checking things out you're
checking things out and make sure
[Laughter]
i never really got on that one i'll be
honest but i did have about 40k on my go
figure so i'm definitely
charged that's fair what about you
colleague
can you even recover after that because
i'm dead that i was dead
he was so funny it was hilarious yeah i
mean
look same thing as physics i mean you
know it was one of those things when you
look at the road map and you go
okay all right you know what i mean and
you know out of respect i'll see it i'll
try it you know
you know the trailer looked fun you know
saying like like you said whimsical it
was you know okay
they're very srl ish kind of suits by
the way i don't know
very very srl vibe i just wish there was
a nativity that would actually use those
suits but you know that they just either
neither here they're there but now look
at the end of the day
that's matter yeah it's fun bragging
rights we're gonna get yeah that's
probably better that's fun bragging
rights we'll get into the specifics in a
few
but um you know look i'm willing to see
you know what's going on you know what i
mean just all right let's see what the
changes are
how different was and then we're going
to get into the percentages
of class winning versus population
i'm very curious how they're gonna
handle that i know e you'll get to it
and um yeah let's just see what it is
and
part of me the only curiosity is
you know for me it's always gonna be the
loop the reason why i'm gonna be in
there
exactly so yeah that that is going to be
key in
this um catalyst that we're going to
talk about
it better do something for me to be in
that invested you know say because that
gun i won't really use it like that
anyway but we'll see yeah yeah and then
just to just
springboard for like a quick second you
said it exactly right like that's how
you get anybody
into any activity in this game really is
you know like you will definitely see me
get
those armor sets all three of them you
know so
so that's so like sure i'm i'm looking
in
you know it's like the main uh like
specifically when i think guardian games
think about the podium right like yeah
which class is gonna win or whatnot but
of course i will definitely get in for
the loot that's just the main
reason why anybody gets a it's a shooter
right so
um kudos to budget yet again for
providing excellent excellent loot
um that's gonna get even even me you
know
involved in it to some degree so
i'm with you so how are you going to be
dropping it over verse this weekend
or next weekend play the game enough
most times sometimes i don't have to
drop much more than breakdowns
bright dust oh there you go yeah yeah
yeah well that works
um yeah i mean for me i mean we joked
about it when the calendar came out
we're like oh here we go
like i mean last time obviously went
through you know all the bounties and
titans got the hell because they thought
they were cheating and turned into
too much in but it was so much like go
grab your bounty go punch your abilities
pick up your laurels like it got really
repetitive for a while and then
everybody lost it because they're like
well titans seem to be winning every day
what the hell
then it just really fell off pretty fast
last time around so
at least with regards to the classes
they do have a specific change of what
they're trying to do with that and they
said
um hunters definitely have more of a
population it's just period it's there
that is
the standard of the game's population so
they state
this time around due to the difference
in classes they said this year
whatever class comes in third place gets
a permanent 10 bonus to scoring going
forward through the rest of the event
so if titans have the smallest
population us crayon eaters just kind of
killed ourselves off it's fine
um if that happens over the course of
you know a week if we're in third place
then we're getting 70 more bone
70 more points going into the next like
you know going into that
forward two weeks so it is ten percent
for whoever's in third place
and at some point if i turn in one gold
medal and you turn in one gold medal
even if there's you know fifty percent
less of me i'm gonna catch up
so they said data wise from if they
applied this to previous years data they
said it was pretty competitive so
as i said we'll be very curious to see
how that hands out do you guys think
that's a fair enough way to like if
you're third you're always getting a
little bit more do you think second
place might get screwed
do you think it might even out in the
end i prefer to i defer to the
mathematician in science yeah
man uh it's something it's tough to say
right
like i'm not gonna be doing all that
math in my head and i certainly don't
have access to all their data from last
year or the year before um of course
i mean hopefully i'm sure they thought
about this the fact that last year's
data was a bit skewed based on
what happened by titans et cetera et
cetera but
um i don't know i don't know you know
like i'm sure i'm sure that they ran
their algorithms i'm sure that they ran
their math
um and i'm sure that it wasn't just
based off of last year's numbers
as well as something a little more
standardized
um it's interesting i say it's just
interesting i
think that it is justifiable most
definitely
um based on pop numbers to to have some
sort of
uh buffer in there to have some sort of
uh you know catch-up mechanism
um especially for you know folks that
are just you know
inherently behind just based off numbers
per class
so yeah it'll just be interesting to see
and i'm glad that they continue
to try to you know mess around with the
algorithm to make sure that uh
you know classes stay in there we're
gonna have titan warlock hunters going
against each other then
you know we're gonna need to have some
algorithm at some point in order to kind
of normalize things
like the the the big big brain idea
would be for
the all the hunters to try and talk to
each other
sandbag for the first little while get
that that boost
and then come in with all the population
numbers and just say it and just
steamroll everybody but
that's not what you have i know that
take away too much coordination well
it takes more coordination but we're all
still mounted
is
like a titan don't think about like they
just back even go about their business
and go on to the next person or whatnot
you know
just like they just think too much of
themselves yes and
like they're selfish with their time too
there's no coordination that's coming
from hundreds whatsoever
so what's gonna do like redo your eulogy
is that how that one works
they're gonna create like a reddit post
and they're gonna start in secret until
the end
you know like the big brains but they
don't ever really show it you know
what's that low-key
they're passive about
and then they might come back from
behind but we'll see i don't know
i don't i just don't know whether
warlocks can come away from their books
too much to even really yeah
incredibly frustrating yo tunes out the
ass but yeah yeah
where's justin at where is it
he drops me yeah i swear to god he
comments like a youtube on my post at
least
every day every year
but i definitely get back on subject i
definitely think that population wise
there needs to be something with regards
to an algorithm to normalize things i
think
i'm glad that bungie continues to
experiment to make sure
that uh the thing that matters most in
the competition is folks effort towards
um towards the dub as opposed to you
know being
already kind of inherently behind based
off of something that they can't control
um you know i.e uh population numbers
yeah so
uh yeah so i was excited to see it i i
did rethink that part of the post and i
was excited to see that they continue to
keep that in mind then yeah we have a
double
pretty much yeah absolutely i mean the
big ones is it's all going to be based
on metals you've got your bronze silver
and gold your standard activities your
strikes your crucible
public events who knows where we're
going to get these we'll probably figure
out once we get in there
the big ones new ones are going to be
the platinum metals
platinum metals are going to be based
around trials
competitive and nightfalls so you got
two pvp one pve
so it actually does work for the pvp
players to have
time that they may not be you know want
to go run strikes or raids or anything
like that but if you run trials cards
i'll be curious if they cap the platinum
at a certain number for the week or is
it like is this your platinum for the
week like you run a trials card you do a
certain number of things
also i want to know
i also want to know the disparity as far
as the trials be that it's a limited
weekend event versus someone who's doing
nightfall so what's the what's the
disparity there like what's the
advantage
right right you have to do 10 nightfalls
versus you know versus right 10 round
win
10 rounds one in a trials matches or
something like what's the difference
going to be that i'm curious because you
have the time limited sake
they also give you comp as well for the
pvp so again we'll see if that's the
same thing with rounds or how they do
that
but those are gonna be the two specifics
and if you do
those two pl two or three platinum
activities you get a chance at a
like special glow you get an all-star
glow
so every friday they're gonna have their
ceremony for the week the kind of
closing ceremony for the week's
activities so we'll start on tuesday so
that friday so tuesday wednesday
thursday
if you want that first all-star glow
you're gonna need to go do one of those
platinum activities obviously
trials won't be there yet so it might be
comp might be nightfalls
then that will last your glow for the
week so that's where
your class emblem is going to end up
showing bronze silver gold or platinum
that's going to be kind of a weekly
basis more for looks than cosmetics
but on a daily basis depending on who is
in first second or third
the main thing that they're adding this
time around is the guardian games
vanguard strike playlist
and they're changing it up to be truly
class-specific
yeah so they finally got that one
focused up and the main reason is the
laurels that are going to be your
currency
to buy sparrows and go shells and these
uh challenge cards and stuff like that
those are all going to be with laurels
so if you run into this playlist
that's where you're going to acquire
most of them because working with the
same class
if you pick up the same class laurel you
get bonuses so it's going to be
advantageous for you to run into this
playlist because that's probably going
to farm a lot of them
since everybody's gonna be the same
classes would you stop dropping hunter
and warlock things i need titan ones
like now
everybody's the same and the interesting
thing is they actually added modifiers
so depending on and it's a daily change
so
you know at first hunters may have you
know the gold early on but as soon as
the population numbers catch up
hopefully the variants will happen
pretty soon
if you have gold the previous day you're
gonna have
extra health extra shields and recovery
and also your kinetic weapon damage is
increased if you're silver
melee abilities recharge faster
elemental damage is increased from
guardians and more heavy ammo's
available
and if you're bronze if you're struggle
busting which i'm sure i will be at
first
uh grenade abilities deal more damage
and recharge faster so i'm guessing
grenadier will be on
and elemental damage will be increased
from guardian sources so
the buff tends to escalate the lower
down the rankings you are
and then on the other side there's
negative modifiers so the higher
you finish the harder stuff working
against you so if you're
gold you're gonna have two negative
modifiers applied
that basically come from the other
classes so the titans are based around
the melee attacks that come in
warlocks are based on airborne damage
and hunters based around radar
so say warlocks are gold
titans were silver and then hunters were
bronze well
the titans would apply to a warlock
group
melee attacks deal significantly more
damage and then the hunter would disable
your radar
if the hunters went into the strike they
would have no modifiers against them
so that's the general idea is the better
you finish you're going to have some
buffs but the worse you finish
the easier it is going to be for you to
sit there and farm and get some more of
that stuff up i wanted to see your guys
thoughts on
what you guys think about that does this
excite you to go into the strike
playlist do you think it's gonna
you know run out of steam be like that
was cool for a day type thing
were you guys falling physics you you're
obviously the guest
what do you think so far i thought it
was interesting like uh
like for me you know the pve activities
that accept me the most
are gonna be the most challenging ones
so i actually kind of like the fact that
we have some additional modifiers
something that i actually have to think
about a little bit
um and i'm curious to see how
uh the buffs are gonna play with the
debuffs as well
you know i thought about that a little
bit so you know if you're a gold place
for example
you're gonna take more damage while
you're airborne but also on top of that
you're going to have more
health and shields as well and that was
interesting as well that if you're
gold then that means that you're going
to have to i mean your kinetic weapons
do more damage but also kinetic weapons
as a whole do less damage than you know
special weapons
um grenades and abilities and things
like that so um
you know it's it's it's an interesting
balance it definitely intrigues me i
will definitely jump in there and see
what the deal is
what i actually like the most to be
honest out of this
um is the fact that you jump in with
with
you're saying you say class i like that
that's fine
that's fine i go for it i go for it you
imagine like titans just like bumping
shoulders with the brothers just jumping
on the strike you know
like in particular when they happen to
see all titans i mean just happened to
us right now and it's just like
oh we're all titans you know world
hunters it's just
that camaraderie you know with negative
degree that tribalism i guess you can
say as well
it's kind of a cool it's kind of a cool
feature it's kind of a cool feature and
i think that folks will be a little more
excited about the mode because of that
because you know you're in there
you're all you all kind of have the same
objectives with regards to guardian
games
um and so you're all going to kind of
like push and push push each other i
thought that was really cool that was
the most exciting thing
for me but um you know a close second
most definitely is i enjoy challenging
pve
um it keeps me engaged um because in
general i find pvp
substantially more challenging simply
off of the
variety that you can get engagement wise
versus right
so the more challenging pde the more i'm
going to be engaged in it
um and so i like the idea of the
modifiers i do like the idea of
modifiers i think it throws an extra
dynamic
in there uh with regards to folks that
are leading
uh not getting complacent you know in
that gold position
um because they know that not only
modifiers are on but also they know that
the folks that are in the last place for
example got that extra ten percent
no folks aren't going to get complacent
so hunters may be able to lead the start
but
as usual hunters get lazy
they don't win they're just going we got
this dub in the bags
you know so easily i hope folks realize
so easily you get that you get that goal
that you can be taken away
like i said modifiers
i think it's really cool i think it's
really cool um i i look forward to
seeing
um how those uh duck buffs debuffs play
off each other i look forward to seeing
the dynamic between folks hopping in the
strikes
with uh with their brothers and their
sisters mm-hmm
i think it's i think still i think you
said it
best friends yeah same thing you know uh
they the actual mechanic the
the 10 you know that the the buffs the
debuffs
i just love that balance like you said
it's not having that
that complacency at the top just because
you won you know
whatever and and the strike playlist man
has the warlock being the warlock
delegation we got our books out we
chilling
and look it's going to be dope because i
mean i could be i could get that
i could run my dorm blade i could run
what's my mask my buggy eye mask with
with a top tree i could do that or we
could go stasis
you know well of radiance i got
different flows the arc bros are out
like nova bro it's it's going to be fun
to see
just your class in a strike and i think
that's cool and uh shout out you know
like i said shout out to stasis as well
we'll see what's up with that i got some
cool bills with the um
the little what is it turret stacy's
turret we're gonna have like
six turrets and arc buddies just dude
you guys are just walking
it all down get real toxic go go with
the what is it the gateway
getaway artist yes and also go with oh
what's my pulse
real dirty with it you know like
whatever we got a lot of things we could
do man but
look at the end of the day it's fun
this is a nice cool to me i'm very
curious to see how strong the debuffs
are in actual
you know actuality you know when you're
out there in the playing field and stuff
like that but um look
i like that they attempt it they're
attempting to do different things with
this this mode and um
i think it's it sounds fun i'm willing
to give it a shot what about you
how did you uh i mean for me new rad
probably said the one thing that i
wanted to say is they're finally working
on
a way to make it to where you're not
working against your fellow guardians
yeah good point good point i'm not like
i'm trying to get all the kills because
i want all the laurels that i can get
from my class as opposed to i don't want
to see those colors on the ground
it's just going to be the only color you
want to see the whole time doesn't
matter who's get it just working
together
and i think that's a positive piece
because it always feels like
all of these things we're doing it's
always like how fast can somebody go
through the strikes so they get all the
kills to do their bounties and leave
everybody else in the dust and now
it does seem that collaboration will
benefit everybody as opposed to leaving
people in the dust you might have
somebody that goes a little faster
but it's not working against your other
teammates it's all kind of collaborative
so i'm hoping
that continues into the bounties because
that's the other piece of it is like
you need to get this be like in strikes
your fire team is what i hope to read
because that would be the other pieces
like you need a hundred kills your fire
team needs 500 kills i would much rather
see the fire team needs more working
together and you know
assisting everybody then i need to get
100 critical kills or snipers
because that's just more annoying for me
to be very oh no they shot that oh no
different people are going to be totally
fine like i can go through and get my
crits totally
and that's fine but on the other side
somebody playing a little slower trying
to enjoy the event for free
they don't want to feel hamstrung just
because they're not as fast as the
people who are burning through
everything so i'm hoping
the other side of the bounties is kind
of thought of as well but overall just
the positive group effort i like
yeah it's also going to increase the
diversity as well somebody so for
example 100
okay as a party you get 300 100 whatever
sniper kills or whatnot oh well this
person's got a sniper on right here
yeah you know so it's just like it you
know encourages diversity as well and
just don't feel the pressure to
necessarily put on a gun that they don't
want to put on okay you know or somebody
else has on
everybody now we got three cyphers yeah
absolutely absolutely the loot is
looking cool
um yeah i'm definitely willing to give
this stuff a shot
and see how this thing goes out man but
yeah i like it
it's a cool little concept where you
don't feel like you're working against
each other
next piece is going to be the metal case
of course um it's going to be where
you're going to store in your metals you
get from your contender cards things
like that
big thing to know for anybody who
listens to this who sees it who listens
to my video
watch the metal case capacity they have
a limit to them
okay and if you acquire a metal once
you're at capacity for say like hey it
can hold five golds i have no idea of
making this number up
and you get another gold like into your
character when this is full
you lose it um so watch your capacity
big time especially triumphs
if you're gonna go and you know click on
the triumphs to get everything that
you've done
make sure your case is empty and don't
overfill it's the biggest thing i just
wanted to say
check your capacity watch the metal case
turn stuff in frequently
make sure it doesn't overfill so you
don't lose things because triumphs you
only get it one time
especially if it's like a platinum you
know give your class the best chance it
can don't lose stuff
the contender cards they said this year
they're introduced a new way to earn
points for your team called contender
cards you'll be able to pick these up
from eva in exchange for laurels hence
why you're going to want to play that
strike playlist to pick all those up
completing objectives and strikes
crucible gambit will earn a gold medal
upon completion
there's also a special platinum medal
that i was talking about will focus on
completing objectives in nightfalls
survival and trials this will be the
only way to earn a platinum medal
completing the platinum will earn you
the all-star status as i talked about
before
for the next um podium ceremony
make sure you complete the platinum
contender card before daily reset on
friday so before 10 a.m pacific
on friday if you want that all-star
status for the weekend and it's still a
cosmetic glow but that's
the general idea so just watch the
capacity
of the metal case that's the only thing
that i've read that you could if you
just sit there and be like oh i've done
like 20 cases
why do i only have five still just watch
that that's so i just want to make sure
you check that one out
good point uh podium ceremony basically
every weekend there's a ceremony that
they're gonna do
third is bronze obviously you got your
different clothes all stars get the
platinum so even if your class does get
bronze
well yeah you can if you at least go for
some of those harder activities you can
have at least the all-star glow and look
good
even if your class is you know having
some struggles
do you factual faction
i mean i'm trying to be reasonable very
diplomatic circadian
[Laughter]
is
kicks in so that's kind of going to be a
thing so give it time
that's the other piece too as like i
hope in
game because not everybody reads the
bungee blog what look is twitter or
youtube
if they see hundred hundred hundred
hunter they're like oh they ran
they ran the board with it i'm hoping
they do something and this is one thing
i wish they would do a little bit more
i like the pop-up messages sometimes but
like make it very specific and say
you know it is going to be a 10 increase
every day i wish they would kind of show
how close
just to know that stuff is in reach
because if they see four victories for
hunters straight away some people may be
like i got my
you know heir apparent i'm out if they
so that's just one of those things i do
hope they show in games somehow
so we'll see one thing i will say that
helped mike last year um which i
anticipate it's gonna happen is you know
dmg is definitely gonna be
on twitter yeah oh no obviously you know
oh you know like
just better watch out
but i do i do agree i wish there was
something kind of like
you know some sort of notification game
or some sort of if you don't just have a
board
you're just like you know scoreboard
yeah yeah or something like that yeah
you can see kind of like progress
you know we'll see right now like the
flags that they had the flat
flags but i would say for that like
daily bonus i'm picturing like
basketball game too much i'm picturing
like
foul lights okay like every bonus you
get get a little like some indication
underneath to be like you're on bonus
seven and now you're seeing that thing
fluctuate a little bit more so some
little in-game indication to be like
you've got the bonus you got the bonus
you're like okay even though we're not
doing as well we're making progress so
that'd be
a little in-game indication would be
nice
no doubt no doubt so we got the armor
sets of course we got our
special glows for the armor this time
around you guys got like
the the bird the hand guard you got the
nice little pop the collar going on
our butt towel is still our butt towel
it's never going to change
hunters with the cloak but the nice
thing is they said about the gear this
time and especially the universal
ornaments
they take shaders well nice and i think
that's one thing they really worked on
is their new kind of shader tech is
actually applying to these
unique armor not quite as like hey i'm
guardian games you can still look how
you want two shader-wise so these
ornaments
maybe you may be empty and some bright
dust to get these if you got it or drop
it a dollar too if you need to
uh warlock delegation we're not we're
not we're not pleased with the uh
i'm asking i heard some people like the
warlocks one so all right the ornament
no doubt we got the bird all right but
that
fake little cape tail thing i'm not
really feeling the two-piece three-piece
suit thing going on
i'm just i'm not there with it like the
titan look clean i'm looking at the
tight i'm like all right i like the
armor set honda look
you know look clean nice little long you
know it's something about that
we look you know what it reminds me what
was that sec
that we lack we clown the titan e
it looked like it was like so yeah
yeah i'm getting them type of vibes
because warlocks say
i'm not flooded yeah like lately the
wall look we got to talk to the artist
but lately i feel like the warlock
lately been getting the short end to
stick with these sets man
i don't think you can really see that
with that which one that the
the bird wing like chest that the world
scout that's that's literally like one
of the best like
they ever set for this this uh this
season i believe right
oh no that one was cool yeah that
reversal that was cool that was cool
i feel like the event sets there's been
a steady decline
in the like i ain't care for the dawning
one i like i
i feel like a decline on the warlock so
we gotta speak to the warlock delegation
that budgie man what's going on man
we used to feel very majestic i'm not
feeling majestic
[Laughter]
you got your plushy ghost you got your
new sparrow that you can get from the
ghost
ships like a clue sleek i always like
the colors on those
but air apparent is your big exotic for
this one and you were wondering about
the catalyst right
yes what does it do what's going on the
catalyst will provide even beefier
shields for you as you can all stomp
your way through the battlefield
okay so just more of a shield thing all
right yeah more
substantial shield i guess they're
probably trying to not make the minigun
too powerful
um but that's mostly it it just seems
like it's probably going to last longer
take more damage pretty straightforward
the ornament's not bad the ornament on
it definitely just plastic
you know your guardian games ornament
yeah that one's actually pretty cool so
that one's gone
i like i don't know why i like the
tennis ball but the little like gatorade
thirst quencher like little squeeze
bottle ghost
for some reason that one just cracks me
up because it's like it's
nailed to like a couple of these
cosmetics and stuff the ships yeah that
is funny
the ships look unfortunately for me they
look kind of generic like what kind of
bullet like how many ships
i haven't paid attention to like what my
ship is every so often be like i'll just
equip it i'd never care too much about
the ships they don't do anything so
overall not too much but you do have
rewards so you got your track jacket
that you can get if you complete the
quest for the sparrow you've also got
your gold pin
there will only be one the winner of
guardian games is the gold pin you can
order so
outside of the statue you'll actually be
able to get the gold pin that you'll be
able to
you know hoist up and order if you are
you know pin collector for any of that
stuff that you've got
hey hey because your new rad is saying
that the catalyst
also it says the shield shield arc
shield durability and partially reloads
the magazine if it's destroyed
that's kind of nice yeah i haven't dated
mined it yet
oh sorry i mean shout out to the new
reds
put the business out man he's on the
inside scoop he's got track
no but i mean that's again that's like
i'll wait to see you but it's like trust
me if you said it
i would probably believe it because he
seems to kind of check out that type of
stuff so
again if you real or the shield break
actually reloads that's actually not bad
to keep you going because then if you
fire it'll spin back up so
i have a question about the airplane
because i've never used it before does
that mean that i mean
not only you get the shield but if
somebody hops in there your teammate
your
member i think it's specific to you i
mean it's like a little sphere around
you so
theoretically it's like at least in
front of you i would imagine if they're
behind you
you should at least be taking the shots
a little bit i would think i thought i
thought it was
individual i i don't think
[Music]
but then again i have not tested that
and i have not seen that somebody said
no it's a personal shield okay
okay so it's like i guess an overshield
it may have a cosmetic look like on the
screen but i guess it's more of an
overshield for you while you use it
versus say yeah as you said a titan
deflector shield
i will say this physics i remember
facing the first time i've ever seen it
was facing someone in pvp
and when they finally get their apparent
to ramp up
it was yeah it was scary i was like wow
they're tanking stuff
yeah yeah so things will be tankier so
if you see a
you know slow walk-in titan walking
around with a mini gun and it's
blue bubble run the other way for a
little while until it runs out of ammo
and he'll be fine
you got a cool emblem i actually kind of
like the emblem that you get from it you
got the little olympic rings thing going
on and everything
and then we've got the thrill of the
chase so
you can as a bunch of rewards if you get
all what is it
76 out of 77 triumphs i think you can do
all but
one triumph or sorry seasonal challenge
to get that triumph it kind of looks
cool but i wanted to ask you guys
how hard are you going on the seasonal
challenges to check every one of those
boxes i didn't know if you guys were
completionist or you're like some are
done i don't really care i'm good
i'm good
right yeah you know
what's called the yeah only the only
ones that i've checked off basically are
the ones that just get checked off
by the nature of me doing what i do but
what i will say
is that i am a little bit more
incentivized to check more off the list
because you get a decent amount of
brightness though
yeah you get a decent amount of
brightness there are some things that
are coming to
you know reverse uh whether it be your
guardian
regarding stuff right now um or in the
near future that
i kind of might want to have some
brightness for so i might have to
actually go out of my way
to do some non i'm not going to take a
gl
[Laughter]
just not me but otherwise
i might you know take something else
take something else in and go to some
strikes or do whatever
you know to get a few more of those
checked off but uh
but yeah the brightness is the biggest
uh
biggest thing for me because there are
some you know some cool stuff coming
into the store
what about you cog have you checked a
lot of boxes in there you've been too
busy with uh the world to try and keep
up with that list
yeah i ain't on that type of time like i
said it's just it's just not me you know
i mean
shout out to we always have teddy that's
teddy's lane oh yeah you have teddy on
that done as soon as you can like you
know he's you know shout out to those
guys
it just that's that's never been the
allure for me
so it's all good yeah i was like i mean
if you want bright dust you get 4 000
bright dust for checking them all but
the time investment to get there
i mean yeah the fact that some of them
are not retroactive is i think what kind
of killed it for me
yeah because like one of them's you know
get a certain number of
uh ranks and gambit you gotta go through
literally a full reset
and you have to do the same thing at
valor and it takes you know 15 000 if
you don't catch on on a weekend
you better play that on the bonus infamy
weekend so that's a key
but then later on they're like hey now
you need like 40 invader kills
and the stuff you did before didn't
count and i know they've done
retroactive stuff so that's one of those
at least in the seasonal challenge
department i'd like to see them
make it retro if i'm going to spend like
20 hours in gambit you damn sure better
count my invasion kills
if i got them over the course of the
season because i don't want to do it
again
and i won't especially right now you
know there's not hasn't been as much and
outriders
pulled me away for sure but like if you
get to a point where it's like a busy
season of gaming i'm not going to go
spend
i'll drop the three dollars that i would
have got for doing the one trap
i don't care that much like my time's
worth a little more so
for sure that's one of those um just
hopefully they'll take some of those i
know they are like
please spend more time in our game and
here's a way to do that
but on the other side it's just not
worth it sometimes
the outright is the show again i'll
write it foul for that one
i was like no game is perfect and
outriders came out kind of busted we
know that but
there is some stuff for out writers that
i'm hoping like destiny is like
they did a couple things they definitely
did some things right so i'm hoping they
look that's all i'm saying no no you you
just speaking
they are because they pulled i mean out
writers oh yes
yeah i'm sure absolutely absolutely so
we have a list of 12 weapons as
candidates for your future ornaments and
you can go vote
i was curious what three you guys picked
man cox chomping at the bed
yeah man i got the um the email from
bungie and bungie had put this out yeah
so i put it
this was tough for me because a lot of
these guns i'm like man
so all right some of them i had to
eliminate because i'm like damn these
ones already got some cool
ornaments already so i had to think like
sunshine i said no because i'm like i
like one of the other or the red and
gold
right so i was like nah you're kind of
good i'm vigilant swing bias officer boy
like man oh sorry so i'm i'm buying
something
like three of those but it was already
exactly i said there's already a bunch
of those
so i think what i did i went
with graviton
i went with trinity ghoul because i was
like
that is really effective you know i want
to i want to ice out trinity ghoul i
think it needs a little bit more
flavor but i i like that right i didn't
do trinity ghouls
because there is one ornament trust me i
actually thought about it impressing my
mind
the only ornament they did didn't change
it much i wanted to be a drastic
different i wanted to look like it
here's another paint job on the same
thing that didn't do it for me i want
these to like change the look of the gun
or oh i think the third one i went
because i did i did it's three right
here no i didn't what
no
i should have went there you're right i
should i forgot about i thought it had
one
so i messed up there so i think i ended
up quoting
i actually actually haven't excuse me i
haven't actually looked at this list yet
so
yeah i was also just looking at the list
and trying to figure out which three i
would
because i like crimson has a nice one
already that i feel is really cool yeah
i think the third one i went
was like mercedes because i feel like
the merciless ones are kind of basic
see like you gotta you gotta buff that
gun before you give me an order
for it true true but i always felt like
the green is playing jane
and they got a white one and i'm like
they need to do something to make me
like it
yeah i will say i think
i'll give mine just i was like i didn't
listen because i didn't have one
graviton lance because i just miss using
that one
uh i can't honestly i'm trying to think
of my third
mm-hmm it honestly could have been
fighting lion and i know that hurts
physics to his soul because he hates
gl's
but like it gets a little bit of a
passion
um i think just because it's like it's
you i'd love to see them put a
completely different cosmetic spin on it
though if they go like you know into the
next season or something like like i'd
love to see it get a
seasonal look because right now i mean
it's mostly got its you know kind of
shine and fighting lionhead yeah if it
went just totally off the wall would be
totally different those i think were my
three
what physics guy what hit him what do
you got always got a little sunshine i
don't care if he's got like 50 ornaments
or not
shot fire that's fine i already know
come over that reddit gold one is
already crispy bro
it's not like it's not like i'm looking
at it like i couldn't get some extra
you're like i want some new hotness new
hotness
doesn't mean i want some i want some
extra
hello
yes
she looked
although i would say graphics has some
really nice ornaments really nice
but nonetheless i would probably go with
the grab labs and that will be my third
my third one would probably be
biggie did you get a lot [ __ ] does
those are the three and of course
they're gonna end up you know
uh i have to toss in i'm sorry risk
runner would have to go in for either
grab lance or busywing
okay okay okay i think i'd probably toss
risk runner in for vigilance okay grab
lance
wrist runner yeah and sunshine i wish it
was super effective
rough concepts of each one so obviously
so we know
kind of a little more because right now
i can be like hey graviton lance says
like it has a kind of a cool one
are we going bit big aesthetic changes
are we going you know a paint stripe
like
i don't need the racing stripe on a gun
i want something bigger
almost like how they preview the
monsters versus yeah
we got a little preview so then we're
like okay we're getting this type of
veggie
i'm in you know what i'm saying are we
getting this type of risk we're not
going to
shoot for some of the duplicates you
know that's a long list that's a long
list i do wish that
while i agree with you and that drives
engagement and i think that this right
here this little competition you know
like a3 or whatnot would definitely go
way farther if they ended up
uh doing exactly what they did for the
two different armor sets for sure for
sure
um but they should they should just
shrink this the list down yeah you know
spread the list down
and then give us give us some concept
art yeah and then that that would have
gone like
massively far as far as engagement with
this particular you know little
competition
so or they could just given us you know
like three different dragon shadow
organs
can it just look different that's it
this is just different
i got some
[Music]
yeah yeah shout out to oh what's that
joke with the fusion grenade
sun starfar protocols one of them on
that list for me
there's a couple that as well like i'm
like bro they gotta fix that
it's just not looking good out here you
know and i know don't get me wrong you
know
some of them kind of like play up to it
with the jesters yeah
i mean the justice of the justice that's
the choice
you know something i dig it but uh
lucky pants to some degree as well like
i'm fake
come on come on
those are some of the times and that's
why i went dinosaur over monster
when destiny doesn't take itself too
seriously it's just like this looks
ridiculous it's some of the times that i
really enjoy it when they're like
yeah this is probably not really in this
game universe we just don't care
every so often those are fun like this
is so broken and dumb looking you're
gonna laugh and that's part of the fun
i feel yeah you gotta respect it and
let's let's be honest too you know like
i'd much rather
wear like a dragon shadow i'm sorry rock
a dragon shadow
esque ornament for a gun versus my gear
yes i will say that so you can make my
man look like a fool and
i'll still probably mess with it you
know but but yeah
there's a reason why i don't like dragon
even though i do feel like going
you
the round and maybe losing the game of
trials you know like
i may to some degree regret it but i
really don't
i really don't i'm with you brother you
gotta look good gotta look good
play good i look good hey there you go
gotta look good i lost but i look clean
as [ __ ]
i feel like see this picture still looks
good even though it's good
it looks good
but that ads can look like trash as long
as it hits them right
hey hey especially if we got a nice long
barrel
oh yeah
yes that's what we talk about oh man
um so as we wrap up one last thing i
kind of wanted to ask
you is as for the future of this game
obviously we have a lot of speculation
on it
if there is say do you have a top
one or two things right now that you
think are
you know that if you could do the easy
button not the armchair developer worry
about all that stuff but if you could
change in the game be like
put ranking ranks and quick like what is
like the one or two things for
your world of destiny that you would
like to see is there a way for your like
you know sunday customs to have a bit
more
you know viability or a spectator cam or
something like what are things that
would benefit
you specifically that you'd like to see
more short term
than say destiny 3 or maybe like witch
queen somewhere in there okay so we
asked
specifically me or benefit the game i
mean either
whichever where you i mean you know are
you benevolent to the
the general public or you're like this
one's for me
you guys get one and i get one i mean
however you want to do it let's take
community over everything
because the thing is if it ends up
benefiting the community i always
believe it ends up benefiting me
always trickles down to the individual
oh it's true so
the number one thing i think for pvp
um not necessarily number one but a huge
one is you gotta separate out the
competitive folks
the really higher skilled folks from the
casual folks
nice time it's time there's no better
time than right now in my mind so you
need we need a ranked
you know we need we need a place
for folks that are more experienced than
pvp to be
so that they are not in quick play 24 7
you know like driving folks that are
just trying to either play very
casually or um folks that are just
coming into the game like you like
players etc etc that are super exciting
because the gameplay that they saw you
know on this twitch channel or this
video or whatnot but they
aren't yet able to emulate but they're
working on it but you know they just
jump in and they don't even know
what to do like we need a separate place
for that because
you know even just even like i said
somebody that's just been playing the
game for like five six
seven years substantially higher on the
skill
on the skill you know spectrum than
somebody that just came in this year or
something like that
um especially for the folks that don't
have a lot of time necessarily to invest
specifically in
improvement based uh crucible especially
for the folks
again that just play want to play a
little bit more casually and improvement
is not necessarily the goal just coming
in
yeah but they can't get any pills
because of the way things are right now
so
i think i think that ranked it it's
definitely time it's definitely time
because we can't no matter what
matchmaking and lobby balancing they end
up putting in place it continues to fall
short of what is actually necessary
um so that that is community-wide like
need i feel like for pvp
right now for sure for sure for the
health of this community
um and uh and i think right now you
can't balance
that get matchmaking balance for that
you can't balance weapons for that
because i say it all the time
really highly impactful weapons um up
you know in a particular skill bracket
may not be that big of a deal dmt you
know deadman sale is not that big of a
deal
in my skill bracket but in mid to low
tier you know it's a huge deal on pc
right now it's a huge deal
a huge annoyance um gl is the same sort
of way 128 is the same sort of way it
varies depending upon what steel bracket
and when we talk about
uh specifically you know the mid to
lower skill bracket
like those are the folks we really need
to make sure that it's not necessarily
about protection it's just by giving
folks different
areas to play based on what their goal
is for their gameplay yeah that's number
one
pretty sure i think that's huge right
now yeah at the front of like very very
close to the front
line um
i don't know like the second thing is
just
i don't know i don't know honestly i
think it's to start like i'm gonna just
go community why it's just our discourse
we're gonna talk to each other the way
that we listen to each other the way
that we
interact with each other and share our
perspectives like people gotta start
listening
you know people gotta start listening
it's not about
one person being right or one piece of
person being wrong it's just about like
look
i don't know your perspective because i
don't play at your level on your
on your platform with the weapons that
you use
you know against the people that you
normally play play with or against
because i'm not in any of those places
not in any of those places
and therefore when when you tell me you
know like when you open up
like honestly respectfully and you tell
me uh you know your experience
and this particular avenue that you know
i'm talking about that's in this
particular context that i'm talking
about
like i need to listen as a community
member if i'm actually trying to be here
i need to listen and vice versa we share
those perspectives we share those
experiences
i think that'll just go on really that i
mean at least in my community i see it
it goes a really long way to build that
that that understanding
unnecessary to the point where when i
see you know like justin come at me with
the with the yo tune i'm not quite as
like profile because i know this is just
having fun
truly enjoys the weapon um or this
weapon or that weapon you know it's just
like
when i see him i'd see the joy that he
gets from that
yes it doesn't put me off quite as much
it doesn't put me off quite as much
right things that you know used to
frustrate me as much don't frustrate me
as much anymore fighting line is a
really good example because i have some
friends that are
fighting lying connoisseurs once they
gave me a few more details on
oh that actually takes a little bit of
skill you know like this detonation just
right
you know like okay these are the damage
numbers tony you know like it's really
actually quite rare that you
one hit and things like that you need
you give me some of the distinctions
between that weapon
and other breach loaded grade launchers
i'm just like oh okay
fine line kind of gives me a pass now
because you kind of explain not only why
you love the weapon so much and so
deeply and why you put like
you know tens of thousands of kills on a
crucible or otherwise um but also you
just explained that
you know like there's there's a little
bit a little bit of skill actually
that's that's involved in it versus your
your shoe tellers and whatnot so yeah i
think uh you know the discourse when we
talk to each other the way that we
try to accept other people's
perspectives um
and uh yeah i think that can just go a
long way so
those are my two hopes for the community
one for bungie
um with regards to uh ranked separating
out you know yes
playlists with you know what people's
focus is
um and also just you know let's just
talk to each other better
accept some perfect perspectives it just
goes a long way with
everybody just changing their
expectations and just being on a more
level
level mindset you know whatever they
step into
yeah i mean we've had we've had teddy on
before and he said the same thing it's
the golden rule treat other people the
way you want to be treated
and it doesn't matter if you're hiding
behind the veil of the internet it's
like this is still a person on the other
end
that has a perspective about something
and if they're willing to have a civil
discussion
as you've said it could be a different
perspective but it also could open your
eyes to
one new piece of information that
changes your perspective a little bit
and if we can
take a little bit from everybody and
learn now granted if somebody's like
cursing yelling and screaming they're
not worth your time either and that's
there's those people sadly are out there
but on the other side if somebody's
willing to say hey i don't agree with
your opinion but here's why
read it and then you can either have a
logical discussion with them if they're
willing to and i like
that piece of your community especially
in the way you handle yourself on
twitter and the way you bring that in
is i'm not going to get to the emotional
side of this i'm going to get to
you know all of the detail the
nitty-gritty the feel like
and trying but i also want to know why
from my perspective
why does mine differ from yours and
that's one of those big things that i
think you
i agree and then the right thing too
it's like that's when i think a lot of
people
ascended nomad did the video with
nearest and all that type of stuff
some way to say even if that person does
step in to cut like you know the ranked
playlist
they're gonna be down there in bronze
one and even the average player who's
played for
six years of destiny is still gonna
probably eventually like trickle up in
to somewhere you know that like silver
two and yet there's stuff that's higher
but it does it gives you the progression
and then it's also one of those that you
can hope to
you know find that progression to go
forward i think that's one of those
things
the glory and the the valor is like a
weird number
that's just literally like how much time
have you put in it's always been weird
and the glory is the way it like doesn't
go down that fast but doesn't go up but
a true ranking system is like
you know against the people in that kind
of bracket and you're like oh i'm slowly
creeping up and it just
even gives the lower person like they
may not get to platinum platinum may be
too much but if i can get out of bronze
and i can get into silver
i can feel progression and i think that
would be something
that would help a lot of people as you
said give a lot of people their own
you know realm to have a place to learn
as you said like bronze first platinum
there's a point where like some people
will say and i thought in chat there
were differing opinions some people like
you know bronze versus platinum isn't
going to learn anything and generally i
agree with that because there's a point
where if i step in
against say cammy cakes i played with
him one time i was lucky enough i got
dragged through a card
and i watched and i'm like you are 10
steps ahead of my like mouse click
on just moving forward and it's like i
can't
but i was like no playing with somebody
that's different or watching a stream
but to take that and then go apply it i
need somebody closer to me
to try and get a feel for that so the
ranked that would be
i think that would go a long ways and i
don't know
i don't know how hard it would be to
implement but we're not asking for
a bunch of new map development we're
asking for a bunch of new modes just a
way to classify the player base
to give them a way to try and excel yeah
yeah i think you guys nailed it i mean
for me i'll just
wrap it up pretty quickly yeah i think
for me it's always going to be
um incentive and time investment and um
i think
you know what they have to realize
you know about this community especially
if you given great rewards for
for for in-game activities and harder
activities
that is always something that we're
going to gravitate towards and in
reference to trial specifically
i just want it more accessible i want
more casuals to take apart out i want
them to say hey this is a boat i can
participate in
i'm not going to feel stomped they
started the right direction with that
trials bounty
that just hey get in there get some
rounds get a couple kills
you've got a shot at the three like
these are the things but i want
more now i want like you know when i
when you do a nightfall
you know sometimes it's double nightfall
reward weekend you get golf balls you
get shards
like i want this thing to be showering a
little bit more even on mats and other
things
so that there is an incentive there's a
reason to go in there
and i think you know physics said it
best too you know even with the ranking
inclusion in that because you know the
worst feeling is to jump in there and
you can't even get one win
because you know what i'm saying like
you're just getting molly whopped
and it's just like yo what am i even
here for this is not for me
and they run away you know and and
trials is at its best the game is that
this game is at its best
when that population is high and people
legitimately
have a chance they feel they have a
chance to to compete and to get some
some rewards they may not go all the way
to the lighthouse but at least if
they're in the mix and i think
that's the thing that the the hardcore
the sweaty community has to kind of be
like like physics said
you have to listen you know what i'm
saying because we want this game to
survive
we don't want this game to die you know
i mean so that's always going to be me
you know
time and just bungee communication
respect
time investment if you're gonna want me
to do a grand master nightfall
then i i just don't want a plus two on
something on a gun
like no disrespect to adapts like you
know these are the things like when when
there's
meaningful loot substantial loot
you see how the player engagement is you
see how people go oh my god i gotta go
get such and such
you know what i'm saying and and that
that's the thing i just want them to
keep that communication open
and and pay attention to the community
in that respect and
you know hopefully like i said they got
a plan we'll get some news soon
but um yeah i'm looking forward to
getting back in you know it's been a
while obviously outriders would take a
little bit of my time before the
inventory wipe
bad outriders but hopefully they get
that resolved soon i gotta get them
yeah i gotta get them you know me i
gotta get them i gotta get them
inventory
you were really unfortunate a day and a
half
but no i was like no it happened to my
buddy as well it's like and he was able
to at least
that level get back up a little bit and
kind of grind it out but
no that one's brutal and that will shut
a whole world off your loot goes away so
yeah believe me the the restoration
cannot come soon enough for people right
now
but yeah i'll jump in you know guardian
games see what's going on
shout out you know just see what's up
with the podiums this week you know
so i'm looking forward to it forte what
up i see you haven't played it two weeks
i'll feel you brother i'm jumping in
this tuesday
let's link up bro i'll see you in there
so that's what i got
so that's i think all we got for the
show but uh before you wrap
physics tony uh i wanted to ask you
well first off say thank you for joining
us um very appreciate you coming on
enjoy your perspective
enjoy your takes on all of this stuff i
knew that stuff was going to come
uh i can see it in chat yeah yeah they
ready they really they really
they were literally like on channels
physics does not know what's about to
happen right now
he's not done he's not done i got you
though yeah so
that being said while cognito
embarrasses me the floor is gonna be
yours for a second while it's set up
um let people know where they can find
you what you got going on
all the shameless plugs you want right
now because believe me you're gonna have
a minute to do it while i do
last year fitness let's go
so again if folks don't know me of
course
the name is phil physics aka tony uh you
know most folks just call me tony
and you can find me of course all the
links are there on twitter we're quite
active ill physics
on twitch of course uh physics as well
um on instagram it's illest physics we
just started we just started on
instagram and instagram has been giving
me some like errors lately i've been
trying to go like really hard there but
either way i'll be posting there more
frequently uh here in the near future
um of course on youtube it's ill physics
as well
and we're we're trying to figure out
exactly you know where we're
leaning with regards to content on
youtube but that should also uh
that should also ramp up here in the
next like uh next month or so
so but you can definitely catch me on
twitter definitely catch me on
twitch of course um you can always go to
my channel
um and type in exclamation point discord
we have a fantastic discord community
we have discord movie nights on
wednesday nights oh yes
um that's at 10 p.m eastern we've been
doing that for like a long ass time now
and certainly like one of the most fun
if not the most fun like discord night
of the movie
uh discord night of the week uh we just
watched the mummy and the mummy returns
uh
this past wednesday we watched the
greatest showman we've watched
interstellar we've watched
inception we've watched just a bunch of
movies really
that's a hell of a list of movies by the
way those are all awesome like i said
any movie that i can grab off of
torrance
uh but uh but yeah that's wednesday
nights every wednesday night at 10 p.m
eastern that's always
a load of fun and then on sundays uh
something that i do
for my community and just the community
at large in general but
one of the biggest ways that i give back
to my community is it's kind of
improvement focused pvp
and there's something called community
customs where i bring
in um six uh kind of
blossoming that pvp players yeah
so yeah he wrote an article about it in
forbes and everything so yeah it was
really really cool really really cool so
we've been connecting with
a little bit
most importantly just invest in
reinvesting back into my community and
so
like i said we bring in six blossom pvp
players
uh they stream their game play uh during
different games to the discord
and uh a lot of times they'll have like
a guest mentor in there sending nomads
oh that's the homie yeah it was a
end up giving constructive feedback uh
during a game but also positively
reinforce
the stuff that folks did uh well um also
during a game to just help people to
understand you know
where their improvement is where they
can improve and what they're
doing um that they could they should
continue to double down on that
or be successful so just kind of sharing
that uh that six
that those those six years of pvp
experience
so that's on sundays at 2pm eastern
that's community customs but
if you want any updates um it always
goes through twitter
um so follow there and uh anything that
goes live as well and frequently all
those updates are coming through from
the discord as well
[Music]
[Laughter]
great great stuff great story good good
to actually had you at the campfire
talking destiny
and just picking your brand on stuff
because it was really cool and
he's got work to do with that what y'all
making him do hold on oh he's got he's
got the sit up shawl
so all right physics right quick just so
you know we hit the last where we
support
supreme uh getting in shape during a
pandemic you know we gotta we gotta stay
pristine you know you can't go to some
people can't go to the gym
so at the last one we provide that
inspiration for prime
pristine fitness look at the form the
elbows touching the knees
when man is out here barefoot i don't
know why you been for the crib but
that's another story but at the end of
the day
this is what we do here man we are
inspiring
we got to keep people in shape because
right now it is a pandemic man
and health is wealthy all health as well
so that's what we do but also like
health is is huge on mental health as
well
you're out there exercising what not it
can be wonders for your mental health
and
we all need a little bit of that mental
upholstery right now
absolutely man but yeah best salute to
you but i love what you're doing
and the community and i love the fact
that it's positive reinforcement
and and helping people getting better as
opposed to you know most people like get
get
get rekt noob you don't say like you're
actually
helping us a long long way to our
journey yeah to become don't you what's
the word we're using blossoming
i like that we use a blossoming right
okay we're blossoming into a a better
player so salute to that
he said i should do it leave him alone
leave me alone y'all got him today he's
got to work
he is good but uh yeah saluting
officials for coming on man
salute bro absolutely yeah for me you
already know i am at laura cognino on
twitter
appreciate the love and support this
week man it's been really cool to see
i've been guesting on some shows and
stuff like that
and every sunday iron lord podcast is
the lord's day 1 p.m eastern check us
out
big guess if you guys could pull up it
would be greatly appreciated
we will have the legends of obsidian
entertainment
specifically on the outer world so
they'll be coming through we've got the
game designer
and the narrative lead on the latest dlc
murder on iridanos and
even if you didn't get a chance to play
come check it out man talk to some devs
talk about
the writing process development process
with these games that we love
come show support really appreciate it
and of course you know
the last word that uh that that destiny
podcast that a lot of people don't know
about yet again you know come through
i appreciate it
love the support man you guys showed me
an e love he's one of the best to work
with and last but not least got a plug
lord to gaming.net please check out the
site man we've been out here killing
some fantastic riders great opinion
pieces
doesn't matter what platform you like
you know xbox pc
whatever playstation whatever you rock
it's really cool cool it's for the
gamers by the gamers
check us out man and again the support
has been truly
humbling i see a lot of people sending
love and thank you guys and uh
eman what's going on brother who we got
going on man outriders world ambassador
himself what's going on sir when do i
get my loot back talk to the people
did you speak to the execs where do i
get it back what's the date
he gives me such a hell of a time just
because i was lucky enough to be an
outrider's ambassador so
yes yes yes i tease him he's in the
corporate meetings he knows
big time let's go no uh they are working
that's like literally first piece was
the patch for outriders to make sure the
inventory wipes stopped happening i
think they've got that
they patched it on i want to say
thursday they're monitoring it through
the weekend to make sure that holds
the restorations piece too of course so
it's like i don't have a date yet
not sure but it's like they're trying as
soon as they can it's gonna be like
once they know that's kind of stopped
then they're trying to basically make
sure everything goes back in at the same
time so they only have to do that piece
once
it will be additive to your inventory so
it's not going to wipe stuff out they're
going to be giving it to you
so you won't be losing anything so if
you keep playing a little bit grind a
little more
it will go back on so you could play a
little bit more but yeah meet
uh back and forth between played first
part of oreo in the will of the wisp on
wednesday yes
so that's part one of that sequel still
holding up just as good
like that game the platform like it's
sometimes you find games that are just
spot-on and it's one of those just a
platformer
and with like a little bit of combat in
there they kind of jumped in a bit more
of like fighting in this one as well
it's
just the first one was good and the way
they tell the stories in the art design
and everything in this game just looks a
little bit crisper
yes like the detail is just a little bit
lighter everywhere
so it's uh and the music i can just sit
there and listen to the soundtrack so i
think there's a 120 hertz mode in that
too
uh probably is i'd have to look um yeah
they played it on steam so
oh okay i know on xbox series x it does
yeah so
that one's beautiful and then outriders
of course destiny 2 just kind of going
back and forth between those but yeah
kind of wednesday is like my variety day
right now there's a lot of stuff coming
to kind of see what falls in there but
you guys know where to find me streaming
or on youtube or on twitter trying to
keep up with all the antics of our
wonderful community
usually i just kind of sit back and grab
the popcorn and see what everybody's
saying but that's usually the fun part
so but that's pretty much all we got so
thank you guys very much we are going to
go over and raid pattycakes
uh wanted to see you guys over there
encore in the building
thank you so definitely playing some
destiny 2 and trials tonight so
nice gentlemen go over there send him
some love so we're going to wrap up this
episode for you guys tonight
uh april 16th episode 145 we are
been doing this for a minute it always
kind of kills me when we say the numbers
up there
for tonight's episode seriously sir tony
thank you very much sir it was an
absolute pleasure
my pleasure my pleasure ours as well
absolutely uh but we're gonna go raid
paddy cake so thank you guys very much
but for this episode
it has been the last word